[Music]
um no time
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody and we are here look i
have blue hair
well like i said the reason that we're
doing the show earlier is because we're
going to mannequin's vampire ball later
and so i was just kind of like well not
going to have too much time after the
show
to get my [ __ ] together and put makeup
on and wigs and whatnot
so i'm gonna do as much of it as
possible beforehand yeah so then after
the show i can just change clothes
slap on some fake nails put on my
headdress and run out the door
i'm pretty much ready well you're a dude
yeah
everything's easy for you guys you don't
get my boobs like he just put his
clothes on it's like 10 minutes later
he's like i'm ready
got my bondage pants on that's
it just got a zipper right here you can
zip it it just slides out
it flies yeah ready for dominance ready
to dominate
just dominate the hell out of these
[ __ ] is that what you're doing
i guess so i don't know what it is just
let me finish that let me [ __ ]
fantasize
getting ready to go to the [ __ ] club
all right
well maybe dr michael be there in
several hours
maybe dr michael [ __ ] be there he'll
rub on my nipples off i can draw down on
him
he's a nipple rubber he's a nipple
rubber he's a nipple rubbing
dj maniac says is this an official
vampire ball is father father sebastian
in town for no it's not an official one
it's just
um we've been to a couple of though in
tampa
but yeah um mannequins he just he wanted
to do
one i guess like tom that runs
mannequins like well [ __ ] it i'm gonna
do one too
i only just found out about it like a
week ago right and i was like well [ __ ]
because they were talking to us like
last weekend and they're like it's
friday night you guys have to come so i
was like okay
so we're just like maneuvering the show
around yeah
because you know how long it takes me to
get ready for this [ __ ] so i had to
leave your cleavage looks fantastic on
camera
does it yeah okay this isn't even this
isn't my final form this is not
this is not the shirt that i'm wearing i
just wore this one because it's easy to
take off from the front i don't have to
pull it off over my head and [ __ ] my wig
out
down you man those injections man
[ __ ] the cleveland just calling me
i'm gonna try to get in there
but here's the deal he's gonna be
climbing into the creek
[Laughter]
they're already giving sending money
this way what does that say yeah thank
you ken
i can't see that for some drinks because
you look [ __ ] amazing oh thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
you should see what i i just bought her
some
some new stuff too yeah he was just
showing me i got her like a marilyn
monroe style dress you know
like a halter dresser this [ __ ] red
bright red pvc it's going to look good
it's cool looking at the bottom just got
to get her the right [ __ ]
bra to go with it because it's got a
real low back
yeah yeah it's going to have those
little glue on things just glues up
there
i mean you got implants i mean i just
let the [ __ ] swing you know i don't
understand why you get just
you that way you bend over like that
it's like well other people these
[ __ ] look great i don't know why
she's worried about it no it's not so
much the way they look
it's um it's what they feel like okay
it's uncomfortable like you know what i
mean no not really i've never had boobs
yes
on other people yes well that's your
problem right there
yeah i mean that's what i mean it's just
like it's really funny because
it's like the dress and he was showing
me and i was just like man that's really
awesome but immediately i'm like okay um
what kind of dress am i going to wear
with this can i do this can i do that
dude can i do the other thing can i wear
a corset under that no can i wear a
corset over it maybe and that's like you
know what i mean i have to make all
these calculations no i'm going to get
you a new waste center for that real low
narrow waist center to go in there it'll
look great underneath there
pepper says are you backed real low yeah
wear a normal corset with that
you can't wear a bra with it either
unless it's clear and even then right
i've seen like those
clear ones in there right a lot of that
stuff was kind of intended for like a
110 120 pound girl with some serious
bolt-ons
yeah where she's got her own support or
she's kind of flat uh you know if you
got big [ __ ]
boobs even you know
even implants they're they're gonna move
around well there's only a very small
narrow window of clothing that actually
looks good on me i don't think so this
see
i think a lot of stuff looks good on you
you just you're just too hard on
yourself you're a woman
you're seeing it that's just kind of our
thing man you're seeing it through the
eyes of a woman not the eyes of a man
men are a lot more forgiving and they're
into we're into weird [ __ ]
she's got the side wall boobs side walls
oh yeah i know all these all that kind
of [ __ ] you know what i mean
you know you know the woman is well
built if you can see the boobs from the
back
[Music]
yeah pepper said are you pretending to
be vampires or is it just a gothy scene
event
kind of one of the some people get
really into it and they wear the fangs
and everything but it's like i'm not
doing that i'm just wearing [ __ ] that i
would normally wear
it's just a theme usually it has an 18
or 1700s theme
i got all that [ __ ] but my 1700s and
1800 stuff is [ __ ]
so thick and so heavy you can't wear it
yeah it's like a million degrees outside
come on
i'm not wearing all that stuff i could
go full on the sky
yeah he's got he's got like the neck
thing and all that [ __ ] i got [ __ ]
like
five or six jackets from that period
different collar lengths yeah i got some
velvet
i've seen captains and [ __ ] [ __ ] i
got all kinds of
neat stuff like that but it just it's
just too hot
but it's mostly too hot to be able to
wear velvet and wool and
yeah it's kind of a bummer yeah it's a
we get very excited just during the one
day
in the winter when it's cold enough to
wear a coat we're like hooray you're
going like actually wearing some [ __ ]
so it was so he was gonna come and she
was gonna uh guest with us for a whole a
week uh but she said
we don't know what's going on she's uh
having problems at her house
she might have to cancel she might have
to cancel her flight and everything we
don't know
yeah yeah it's kind of looking like yeah
she's got family problems
yeah but you know she's i mean kind of
we're hoping that it
you know we'll just like delay it a bit
yeah or
or things might clear up we don't know
which it's not final yet
yeah we'll see how it goes it's kind of
a bummer
i was looking forward to her being here
yeah pepper said that's because
england is cold and rainy as [ __ ] it is
i've been there um
but yeah florida not so much rainy for
sure
but uh swampy rainy tropical
rainforest rainy you know what i mean so
even after it rains it's like oh boy now
it's hotter than before yeah
actually in that period you know uh
europeans have been here since the
1400s uh late 1400s early 1500s spain
was here a long
long time before um in spain and france
were here a long time before the english
were
and uh they wore that kind of [ __ ] here
they were crazy
how did they not die i don't know and
they didn't even have air conditioning
so [ __ ] man
i my grandmother moved down here to
florida from tennessee in 1958
and her house didn't have air
conditioning for years and years and i'm
like
how did you live in this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
without air conditioning and then she
did get air conditioning and it was just
like uh
like a window unit mississippi
victorians a lot of them are gone now
but the ones that i grew up with you
know in the 80s when they were still
around
they were multi-floored
every room had at least three windows
they were narrow
about a foot and a half wide and they
went all the way up to the ceiling and
the ceilings were 10
12 foot tall ceilings they were [ __ ]
super super tall
and with two with two the windows would
open up right in the middle like two
doors
you know yeah so you could open up you
could walk out too
so i think they left them open most of
the time which meant that the
place would have been just thick with
mosquitoes
maybe they had net uh nets or screens i
don't yeah that's another consideration
i can't understand it
i mean because before we had you know
trucks driving around spraying pesticide
on everything
everywhere i'm sure that there was just
kind of like there was a lot more swamp
back here than those
around here in those days and they had
[ __ ] and [ __ ] velvet furniture
and everything was [ __ ] hand cut
cut and half handcrafted and i don't see
it must have just been moldy and mildewy
and everything must have just [ __ ]
rotted away really quickly
do you i guess you had to just
constantly replace stuff
yeah seriously it's like baking
butterball down here i don't understand
it i can't understand how they lived
like that and then they were taking
dumps and pots and just putting that
underneath the bed
save that for later
[Laughter]
they didn't have any commodes that can't
that would came later they just take a
drop in a damn
pot and put a [ __ ] lid on it put it
in a damn cupboard
yeah i never hand it to a servant say
throw that away
it's just sucking nuts man but they they
made it
i just i just think the standards were a
lot lower well some of them made it a
lot of them died
horribly different preventable diseases
for exactly those reasons now during all
that pasta the
pasta de leon times and [ __ ] during you
know spanish and french explorers that
were down in this area
1500s and 1600s
i think they kind of what you would call
in modern part you know
in in in the 1800s parlance would be uh
i think they went engine
well yeah like because you couldn't walk
around all that [ __ ] armor and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that they brought
with them from the honky motherland
you'd have to put all that [ __ ] up just
walk around yeah like the second i got
here i'd be like yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what are the natives wearing yeah okay
give me that loin cloth give them some
underwear
now you just walk around and [ __ ] that's
probably what they did and then they do
yeah you can't believe them and they do
wood cuts and [ __ ] paintings like
they were all in their armor and all
that [ __ ]
if they wore armor they wore that [ __ ]
only when they were going to some kind
of a battle
that's when they got fancied up for the
portrait yeah you know what i mean it's
like getting dressed up to go out
zach says oh my god jenny your hair or
is that a wig yes it is
um you know we're we're going to the
vampire ball after the show yeah
so look i have look i have horns also i
know it's not vampire
it's more devilly but i forgot about
that yeah see
no that's cute why are they crooked yeah
you can't see them
you sort of can not on camera get move
over this way
yeah they're little ram horns
yeah yeah
now i'm messing my hair up this is
exactly what i didn't want to happen
yes these nests got sexual problems
don't we all yes
back then the velvet was made of natural
fiber like silk much easier to bear in
hot weather yeah i guess
i guess so uh synthetic um fabrics are
kind of a lot
harder to deal with yeah but i have a i
have a double-breasted
coat from europe that is real um
uh what he called real velvet it was a
real expensive
i think i got that from black rose it
was like 200 something bucks for that
jacket
back then i went to black rose and
camden market when i was in london and i
used to wear that
used to wear that when i went to uh man
ray in boston when during
in the winter with snow and it would
be you could just wear just a velvet
jacket walk through the snow and you're
fine
you didn't need an overcoat that shit's
warm you got into the clothes you got
into the club even in the wintertime you
just [ __ ] roasted
do i rarely ever wear it and uh when you
look at it you could tell that was like
some 1960s [ __ ]
a [ __ ] austin powers [ __ ] cut it's
like
it's like something from like something
from the 60s shagadelic man yeah it's
all shagadelic
black black velvet stuff bee's nest says
i still wear hammer pants
and then dj maniac said uh i have hammer
horror pants they're covered in blood
hammer pants that's the ones with the
crotch went all the way down to the
ankle
pretty well yeah or down past your knees
i feel like yeah
those those were things for a minute for
a minute that's so nobody would know
nobody would know you were wearing a
diaper
that's what they were for that was
somebody that had to wear depends and
they were embarrassed about it
so they thought that they would make a
whole fashion trend about it
m.c crabber all right
do we have any kind of shout outs or
anything like that before we start this
uh we do yeah and i think i mentioned
this on the wednesday show but like i
said i always like to do them on the
main show as well we have a new patron
named esther so thank you very much and
welcome
also wanted to give a shout out to all
you other mystery science theater fans
out there because i know there are some
yeah
they have started another kickstarter
they're going to essentially
they want to do a whole new season and
they're going to essentially start their
own
it's not i don't know if it's
necessarily like a streaming service but
they're going to start their own thing
like where they're gonna have their own
live events and they're they're starting
their own studio like they're in virtual
studio i guess
and they're gonna have like live events
and [ __ ] like that from there and
they're gonna put all the episodes up on
that instead of having to go through
netflix because they canceled them
so they put up their kickstarter i
believe yesterday
and their goal was two million dollars
and they got it in less than 24 hours
this all goes back so they're heading
toward 3 million 3.3 million is their
next uh
target this is this this goes back to
what i was telling you all wednesday
when i was getting drunk
and y'all shut me down saying i talked
too much
wait who said that i don't know somebody
in the audience
talks so much it puts you asleep like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm i'm struck
down shutting this goddamn [ __ ]
but i was [ __ ] i was pretty loaded so
it goes back what i was telling you
about the older a
system gets the more scammified it
becomes the
the more in debt it falls into the
higher its overheads
the less of a deal it can get give you
and the more
[ __ ] the the more the quality [ __ ]
sucks and it's always replaced by a
leaner and meaner system
just like what happened with punk rock
music okay with [ __ ]
that's what happened to prog rock punk
rock happened and that was the end of
prague rock
all right uh it's gonna be some [ __ ]
like that you don't
need netflix you don't need these big
studios
you don't need all these middlemen and
they're [ __ ] panicking
they're [ __ ] panicking because they
are rich
they got rich generations ago all right
they feel guilty about how rich they are
i don't think that's i think they say
yeah that's what all that virtue
signaling and everything that they do is
about because they
feel [ __ ] guilty because uh for about
two or three generations they've been
scamming
not three or three generations how many
two
probably two depends on who we're
talking about actually
but no they're scamming and they know
they're scamming so
you know they're gonna [ __ ] they're
gonna [ __ ]
virtue signal and do anti-racism you
know of course what course because
you know who's not gonna get on board
with that and that's free that's cheap
that's easy
but are they gonna adopt real [ __ ]
socialism like bernie sanders no
i'm gonna get ready they're gonna get
rid of him they're gonna put some
corporate [ __ ] hack up there
and then they're gonna say yeah
anti-racism and they're gonna
it ain't it's all the [ __ ] act it's
all an act they don't believe in
anything
all right uh i don't believe them and
they don't believe it and
all these old rotten institutions
and corporations are going to [ __ ]
fall fall apart
by lean and mean creators with their own
technology technology is now
democratized
i mean jenny just got a damn new phone
that can do
things that 30 years ago was just
undreamed of
i finally got a new she got a brand new
phone so we'll be able to upload
probably like five years overdue
yeah we'll be able to upload some [ __ ]
from the from the club and put that up
on social media you guys would know this
unless we get too drunk yeah
he'll take video of me throwing up into
a great like that girl last week
no longer takes no longer takes two
million dollars of equipment to record
[ __ ] 10 minutes of [ __ ] footage
you know it's not like that anymore
so uh you know the old ways are dying
sandra says i still don't know what
mystery science theater is even though
you talk so much about it she's in
germany yeah
um oh it's hard to explain i can explain
it
are you going to be shitty no i like
mystery science thing okay
mystery science theater started off as a
television program
back in the early 90s actually late 80s
89 late 80s
mst 3k that's usually what people mst
3k that's what they all call it mst3k
and it's
and it's got a huge fan following and
what it was
is it was a show
where you watched old b-movies they were
terrible
yeah but there was a wrap-around story
behind it about a guy who was trapped in
space with his robots
and they're watching these they're
forced to watch these movies it's an
experiment it's like an experiment
they're trying to direct you
forced to watch these movies and you're
going to watch these movies along with
the little robots
you can see the silhouettes the little
robots heads down at the bottom of the
screen like they're in the movie theater
with you
and as this [ __ ] [ __ ] movie plays
out they're in there making comments
about the [ __ ] movie and it's
hilarious
it's delightful it's very funny i mean
it's you have to have a particular sense
of humor yeah
but here's the problem with it
[Laughter]
you have to be very knowledgeable and
very educated about
film everything culture about everything
every [ __ ] thing
because these little robots and then
their little friend in
different seasons had a different guy
the comments and the jokes they're
making about this b-movie
do obscure [ __ ] references to books
written in the 20s or the [ __ ]
whatever you know what i mean
man they've even made some like stuff to
from like ancient greek plays
[Laughter]
if you're not if you're not real
well-rounded you can check you can say
in the movie
you can go back online and say in this
episode
at this mark why does the robot say this
and that and it'll tell you what they're
talking about to explain the joke
because some of the shit's real obscure
so jenny because she's a nerd she knows
most of the [ __ ] i own that
i sit there and just kind of like giggle
and most of it i don't get some of it i
get
some of it's real low brow humor like
they start singing all [ __ ]
yeah he likes the music oh man when they
start singing i [ __ ]
bust up laughing because they're they're
they're they're musical
their musical humor is perfect it's
spot-on
it's just so that went on
that program went on for many many
seasons it even ended up on netflix
and then they even had a multiverse or
a what would he call it uh uh well the
people that branched off from the
original branches
there's cinematic titanic there's rift
tracks right
which is awesome riptrax is good too
there's a bunch of free ones on yeah
rip track rifftrax is just uh you get a
you can get her
you can either watch a whole program and
they'll do it live
where they're riffing on a movie it's
the same guys from mst
3k or sometimes it's just a recording
that you press
when the movie starts and you hear them
commenting over the move
yeah it's like it's their own commentary
but their own commentary they're trying
to get around licensing restrictions and
stuff but it's [ __ ]
but some movies if they can get the
right to it then they'll just sell it as
a package
they have a whole website they do like
old educational shorts they do
they've done pretty much any movie you
can think of shitty ones are good ones
rifftrax has done it yeah now is is uh
was the is it still up on netflix uh the
old seasons are
there's they did a season and a half
which was mst 3k the return
yeah um and that was 12 episodes i want
to say nine episodes or 12
and then they did one that was called
mst 3k the gauntlet and that was six
episodes and they're good
if you don't know the whole history of
the show you can start on the netflix
ones
but if you see the original ones i mean
yeah they're good too yeah i like all of
them
but they all have their different vibes
because like i said joel hodgson is the
guy
that started it back in the late 80s
he's like a comedian and he's a magician
back in the old days he's being
letterman and stuff and then
uh he was on it for five seasons and
then their head writer mike nelson took
over
and um i tend to like joel is much more
like laid-back stoner kind of humor
um mike is a lot more acerbic uh
and i tend to like that better so i
honestly i think my favorite season is
the last one they did on comedy central
because it was
mike and the original robots um
you know i know that josh was the
original servo i know but um
mike and the original robots and dr
forrester and frank
yeah and that was like only six episodes
but those are probably my favorite ones
i even liked the ones that were on the
sci-fi channel
like seasons eight nine and ten the
problem is that you can't go back in
time
and watch all the old ones in order
very easily and it would take years to
get through them all because there are
so
many so so if you're in germany
and you want to know what mst 3k is all
about just go on the netflix version
and watch the two seasons that they have
there you'll have a good time
it's a recreation very high quality
recreation of what the show was about
you had to change some things like
netflix doesn't have commercials
and the original television program you
had commercials
and there were intros and outros to the
commercials and
there was music playing and to get that
vibe
of it being on tv the netflix version
takes breaks like they're going to do a
commercial but they don't do it but they
never get but they do like a bump just
goes like that
it goes back to the thing and to make
you feel like you're watching the
television
oswald is on there a lot of [ __ ]
dudes in costumes dancing and felicia
day
everything has secret meanings like you
know there's a ton of callbacks yeah
much you know it all has secret meanings
to other movies like in the new netflix
version
the guys in the background dressed up as
the band
singing they're in these skeleton
costumes and they're talking about
in for man yeah that was the bad guys
from a crazy they don't tell you that
yeah they're crazy they're just like a
little easter egg
yeah well the the awesome thing about
mystery science theater is pretty much
everything is a reference yeah to
something else
and most of the time thank you very much
moonwalker
i have to go back to work now tom and
jenny you guys look hot and i wish you a
fun and great night tom thanks for
adding me on instagram today thank you
thank you
that's from julie thank you very much
that's awesome
um if you're like if you're new to mst i
usually
recommend and you know this is just me a
lot of people will say oh see one of the
older episodes like one of the classics
like manos or pod people or something
but
i would say go for something i like 80s
movies like cheesy 80s movies and it's
a lot more fun for them to make fun of
so i would say uh space mutiny is a good
one
uh hobgoblins is a good one because that
movie is just like appallingly bad
but like in a really entertaining way so
i would recommend hobgoblins or space
mutiny
i say just watch the netflix ones
because the the humor in them is
kind of put down is a little easier
because it's not so obscure well the
nice thing about it is that there's some
high brow humor but then
it's like they'll make a joke about like
[ __ ] aristophanes and then they'll
make a poop joke yeah
and then they start singing it's all
over the map
i just bust up when they start singing
because they're they're they're
they're musical humor is just perfect
and
and it musical humor is emotive it's
about emotion
so i'm more keyed into that intellectual
humor doesn't
doesn't do anything to me i'm just like
yeah either i don't understand it i do
understand it but i don't find it funny
but somebody slaps somebody else i'll
think that's funny
yeah yeah that's kind of you know some
of their jokes are like
multi-tiered because sometimes they'll
be referring to
it's kind of hard to explain but they'll
be referring to some a situation in the
movie and calling back something else in
the movie that they're watching
but they're also referring back to some
other movie
that had like a similar situation or
something like that so you kind of have
to know
like a couple degrees back like what
they're talking about well she's in
germany and i don't know if she's a
native english speaker that's why i'm
saying go to the netflix ones it'll be
the easiest one to
yeah those are a little less yeah
they're less weird yeah and because like
the older ones they had a lot of older
references particularly they had a lot
of references to like 60s and 70s
uh really obscure american tv and
commercials and stuff
so if you didn't grow up with that like
you might not know what they're talking
about most of the time
but um you know i'm just i don't know i
i
i guess i'm i'm kind of like the same
age i'm a little bit younger than they
are
but um i remember a lot of the tv shows
and movies that they're referencing
just because i saw them as kid so that's
sandra asking about this yeah yeah
yeah sandra just watch the netflix just
watch the netflix ones
yeah she needs to see at least one
episode the easiest ones to start with
are the netflix ones but keep in mind
though that the older ones that's not
yeah they're all the people are
different and all the voices are
different
yeah so it's the same general setup
but if you see like the original shows
it's all different people
yeah like in the voices of the robots
it's the same robots but the people
doing the voices are different
they changed out the people doing the
voices a couple of times you're asking
what our instagram is it's 13 o'clock
right
yeah i think it's third oh wait is it 13
o'clock or 13 o'clock podcast one of
those
yes you'll find it yeah we do have an
instagram wait do you have an instagram
on your own i have my own instagram okay
because i just changed mine i had a
jenny ashford one and i just never
posted on it so i just
was like [ __ ] it and i just changed that
one to i don't really use instagram to
uh
communicate that much i do i i mostly
just post [ __ ] about the show on it i
mostly just
use it to keep up with like uh the
fitness
industry you know what bodybuilders are
doing the male and
female bodybuilders and just look at my
competition you know
look at that look at my competition
for mr universe well no there's no way
i'm gonna beat that
hi bookie i thought i heard the door
creaking yeah
just try to keep keep keep my eye on i
know you know it's what's possible
for a guy my age and what can be
achieved and how they did it
um and also like uh look at her sneaking
in from the side
looking at looking at goth girls what
they're wearing what they're doing which
helps me
[ __ ] you know shop for jenny and of
course i'm into
into aesthetics what's funny you know
probably coming across on the show the
way i come across
probably doesn't translate real well i'm
really into girl [ __ ]
i'm really into girl [ __ ] it annoys
jenny but
wait does it i think so i'm in a girl
clothing and stuff so no wear this wear
this where that you know it's just like
i'm not your doll or whatever you know
but
i i like well it is kind of stuff well
yeah i know i get that but there there
comes a point where
you know i i'm i'm my own person yeah
like you don't really i don't really and
also i really really really don't like
being told
yeah she's like she's real pig headed
and i just that's not pigheaded i just
don't like being so what to do
if i was a dude nobody would say i was
pigheaded
i just i like female fashion i kind of
keep up with it but
the goth fashion you know i don't really
care
which is its whole thing i don't even
care about mainstream females i don't
even know what's going on in the regular
fashion thing whatever it is they're
wearing
you know call tom btk sure yeah somebody
should
yeah yeah if i'm gonna dress up a
woman's clothing and put them very much
take my own grave and take pictures and
[ __ ] oh my god if you would let me
take a picture of you doing that i will
give you five hundred dollars no you
would
no i probably wouldn't maybe maybe two
hundred dollars
i had to get them to pay that y'all five
hundred dollars
i'll dig my old grade dress up put an
anime mask on and bury myself
oh my god that would be so [ __ ] funny
yeah you got to [ __ ] set up a [ __ ]
kickstarter for that
look what you doing what are you doing
oh she's i got a big old [ __ ] saucer
eyes
i'm glad that i closed well she came
down here and she was like looking like
i'm going to jump on that [ __ ] and i was
like no you better not
i know everybody wants to talk they want
to ask all these crazy ass questions
but we got to start this second show we
probably did
i mean what time is it do you know what
time it is
5 30. oh okay we still got loads like i
said
the makeup in the hair is like takes the
longest yeah i mean i kind of already
have an idea of what i'm gonna wear so i
can just slap that on and slap some
nails on
and then we can get the [ __ ] out of here
it's not and we don't have to be there
literally when they open
and we don't have very far to go no it's
very close we're going to get some food
tonight
we're going to we going to go to
chantals probably go to shantels
i wonder if they're going to be doing
some karaoke tonight you know they're
going to be doing good karaoke
maybe you'll be drunk enough to do
something yeah going to get will get up
there and start singing
well he doesn't need any encouraging
he'll just do it anyway i wanted to get
some video of that [ __ ]
i can't remember what song he sang
though i was kind of
i'm not i wasn't that drunk i remember
him getting up and singing but i can't
remember what song it was
all right so this was the topic that
everyone voted for
look at pokey back yeah yeah she's
sitting there blinking at me i know
she's doing this low blink i was gonna
say i think i got my first slow blink
from
path kitty today yeah when i took him
some food
and he ate the food and i petted him and
everything and then he sits by the bench
and he just looked
over at me like that and like slowly she
looked at herself in the mirror
she's so weird yeah she looked at
herself she stares at herself in the
mirror
yeah and then sometimes she goes yeah
talk to herself
it's the weirdest thing i've ever seen
she does that pretty much every night
like she jumps up on the bathroom
counter and looks in the bathroom mirror
she's a weird kitty david june says i
was always a joe bob briggs guy
on shutter his uh drive-in theater
whatever is uh
that new season just started on shutter
so i gotta catch up on that
because i think there's a couple couple
shows that i
didn't see did you see what bridgette
said what
my husband is the same way as tom and
jenny i said the same thing i'm not your
doll
yeah see well it's you know you don't
like having other people's will
imposed upon whatever
[Laughter]
you know i'm a power top
[Laughter]
i'm a leather daddy
[Laughter]
i'm not a celebrity i'm not a dub daddy
i'm not a yeah
yeah yeah i'm a heterosexual leather
daddy
[Laughter]
that's really funny yeah yeah it's like
you know
i'll i'll make some concessions but
don't go too far at that show cause i'll
be like yeah no
all right so like i said we're gonna
talk about some
creepy disappearances again you guys
seem to really like this topic actually
i really like this topic as well this is
our fifth volume of this i think
yeah we may have done a lot of these
pogos um
well the sad thing about it is that so i
go to like one of those missing person
sites
and i'm just like okay so i need like
you know a handful more cases to do and
i had to check
like our past shows thank you gadgie
when you guys head out i'm going to take
my beer to the kitchen lean on the
counter pretend we're allowed in pubs
over here
soon don't worry um but yeah so
i had to go back to our all our old
shows like the last four volumes and
check
to make sure that i didn't repeat
anything um
i'm pretty sure that i didn't but if i
did i'm sorry
uh but like i said it's really
depressing because you go to these
missing person sites
and there's just i mean
just pages and pages and pages and pages
of people that are messing and they
don't know where they are
and it's like the most terrifying thing
i've ever seen
jen allen says hi i'll like the hair
jenny thank you yeah it's a wig
uh wearing this out tonight later and
like i said i had to already do my
makeup so i was like well i might as
well put the wig on too because i have
to put the wig cap on and then it's like
you know what i mean it's
it's this whole thing like i said i have
to have i have to be all like tactical
with how i get ready to go out because
it's so
complicated it has so many moving parts
so one of the first ones that i want to
talk about
um and i wanted to talk about this case
for it's pretty old but i wanted to talk
about this over a couple of reasons
one because if you guys are following my
flickers of fear my movie reviews
i just reviewed the 2020 movie shirley
with elizabeth moss which was kind of
about
wasn't about shirley jackson but she was
like a character in it
and in that movie she was working on her
novel hangs a man
and that novel was partially based on
this girl's disappearance
another thing too is that when this
young woman disappeared she disappeared
from this place in vermont
where several people disappeared during
a five-year
span so many uh that they call it the
bennington triangle
because so many people have disappeared
so i talked to yeah i want to talk about
that a little bit too
because uh yeah that's pretty weird but
like i said i have some more cases that
i kind of chose
sort of at random so uh you ready to
yeah get into it yeah go ahead have you
guys ever done a show on the national
park disappearances not yet but that is
on the list i do
actually want to do that this one
uh this first case paula gene weldon um
she kind of disappeared i don't know if
it was a national park but she
disappeared from like kind of a national
like a hiking trail or whatever
so this happened back in 1946
so paula weldon she was a sophomore at
bennington college as i mentioned in
bennington vermont
now the last time she was seen was
december 1st
1946 she worked at the college in the
dining hall
so she had worked through the breakfast
and lunch shift and then she came back
to her
dorm room dorm room and she was talking
to her roommate
and then for whatever reason she says to
her roommate um you know i'm gonna go
take a study break and i'm gonna go for
a hike but she didn't tell
her roommate where she was going exactly
so apparently she leaves the campus
about
2 30 p.m or a little bit after that now
they don't think that she was carrying
any money or if she did it was like just
a little bit and
um they also found later on she had left
behind an
uncashed check that her parents had sent
for her living expenses at the college
um
also it was kind of cold out and she
didn't really have a coat or anything
like that she you know she wasn't she
wasn't really dressed for the weather in
other words
now she was actually spotted hitchhiking
and i know what you guys are thinking
but that's not what happened she was
hitchhiking
near the campus and someone going by in
a car
picked her up at 2 45 pm now she told
this person now like i said this is the
1940s
so you know hitchhiking like i said it
happened a lot in the up until the 70s
until
serial killers started killing everybody
doing that but um
i guess you could still do that back in
this time
or not because she didn't she she's met
but it wasn't this person that picked
her up i'm just saying it wasn't
necessarily hitchhiking that did her in
this time
because she was hitchhiking the guy
picked her up at 2 45
she said that she was going to hike on
the long trail
off route 9 which is uh near glastonbury
mountain
so the driver dropped her off about
three miles away from where she was
going
and a bunch of other people saw her like
after that time
she was actually just walking along the
trail just going for a hike just like
she said that she was going to
apparently
now the last confirmed sighting of paula
weldon was at 4pm
at this point she talked to a dude on
the trail
and uh she asked him like how far it
went and he said oh it goes all the way
to canada
um at this point this was december in
vermont
so the sunset was fairly early it was
about five o'clock
p.m and it started snowing a little bit
after that
uh you know and it snowed quite a bit i
think it was like three inches of snow
so like i said it was pretty cold out
now after she had asked that dude on the
trail
where you know where the trail went to
or how far it went
nobody ever saw her ever again she just
disappeared where was this again vermont
okay
bennington vermont probably a real rural
area huh
um well it was right near a college okay
so
not really no somebody got her now
interesting okay so
her roommate uh was worried about her
because obviously she
uh you know discovered that she hadn't
come home the night before
um and later that morning the roommate
uh you know told the school authorities
about her disappearing
now at this point the students at
bennington were supposed to
sign themselves out only if they plan to
stay out past 11 p.m
and then when they came back they were
supposed to check in with the school
security officer
obviously paula weldon had not done
either of those things
and also not surprisingly she didn't
turn up at her classes
on the following monday either at which
point the college officials notified her
family and notified
the police so since everybody knew that
she'd gone out hiking on the long trail
they all went and started looking but
they found
nothing no sign of her at all um
this is very unusual this was 1946 and
in 1946
vermont had no state police i guess all
like all their police were local and in
fact it was
this particular case that made them pass
the law
to have a state police force so there
you go but they didn't have it then
so i guess there was some kind of inner
you know departmental
wrangling as there always is what
nothing well they wanted a state police
force because it's more centralized and
you could make sure that they had the
better training
yeah you know during this era
during this era cops were just nothing
more than a mall cop there
you know that that's all it was there's
a mall cop that walked around they
didn't have any special training or
anything
i mean uh when you think of police like
you got protesters saying to fund the
police and [ __ ] nowadays
it sounds insane it kind of is insane it
is insane all right
but there's also an argument for it
because
for a longest time the united states
didn't have police
no no there wasn't any professional
police forces
there so you can optionally not have one
but if you're not gonna have cops then
you have to have everybody's gotta have
guns
you have to take care of yourself and uh
you're gonna want to bring back things
like dueling and things like that you
know
[ __ ] you will have anarchy
but you know a lot of countries are like
that have been like that forever
um so yeah of course
yeah well like i say that you know so it
was kind of harder for them to mobilize
and centralize because they didn't have
state police
um but they had people from other states
like you know cops and stuff from other
states like massachusetts connecticut
new york
they kind of came in to help looking for
this young woman
now at first they kind of thought that
probably maybe
she had just wandered off uh into the
mountains and had died somewhere and
died of exposure
but since they did all these massive
searches and they didn't find
any sign of her whatsoever they started
thinking maybe
maybe somebody took her somebody along
the path like somebody kidnapped her and
killed her and you know buried her
someplace else so they started looking
into her background
um to see if maybe she you know knew
somebody that had done something to her
if she had left
of her own accord maybe she was having
some problems um
they apparently found she didn't really
have a steady boyfriend had never really
had one
she was a good student she wasn't
flunking out or anything she was an art
major although she'd been thinking about
switching her
major to botany i believe because she
became was becoming more interested in
that
um they said maybe like according to
family and friends they said well she
was kind of like a little bit depressed
at the time of her disappearance because
you know like i said she was thinking
about changing her major or whatever
but you know nobody thought it was
anything unusual
you know what i'm saying so they're
saying well she wasn't like sad enough
to
you know kill herself or run away or
anything um and all
her belongings were left behind um and
usually like you know as
the family usually says it's like she's
not just the type of person that would
just take off without telling us now
even though from that day to this from
1946
to now they have not found a single
hair of this girl's head
anywhere along that trail no one has
ever found any remains no one has ever
found any anything
read what my friend grampter says uh in
the comment section there's got him
granters that's his that's his screen
name
he's a retired policeman that i grew up
with from high school
you read what he says says
i worked as a federal game warden in
eastern oregon in the 1990s
every year a hiker a hunter would
disappear in the high desert sometimes a
body would be found other times it was
like the remote terrain just gobbled
them up bones clothes and everything
yeah see that's kind of where i'm about
now i'm not now i'm not saying
that she wasn't murdered i mean she
might have been murdered
but or she might have wandered off
gotten lost and died of exposure
you know so yes they do these extensive
searches of the area
but these are pretty remote areas so
it's entirely possible
i think she was probably murdered and
hidden
and then um i've said many times before
in the uh in the show you know i've done
a lot of times in the [ __ ] field you
know with the army and even before that
you know at my dad's place out there in
[ __ ]
in mississippi hunting if you leave
something dead out overnight
in the woods in the south you come back
the next morning it'll be gone
you won't be able to find it i left a
turkey out
long story but i left the turkey out and
i'll go back get it later
came back a few hours later and it was
gone i don't know what happened to
turkey it was dead turkey
well animals probably came by we're like
woohoo yeah
so you put a human body out there in an
area where you know
dead bodies give off smells that an
animal can
smell miles away we can't smell it but
they'll come and get it
nothing like the waste free meat now she
may have been
sure may have been killed by a person
but she was us on that path i'd like to
see where this terrain
was at the time like to see what the
conditions were that season
because there's another another chances
that she may have been grabbed by a
mountain lion
that's possible that's possible too
they'll wait along a path
now mountain lion won't prey on a human
normally but if that
mountain lion's sick or maybe are really
hungry
or maybe killed a child a human child at
one time
and got a meal off of that then they can
kind of get the habit and they
start thinking well you know you can eat
humans
and they start doing delicious kind of
meat
but even not that i would know here in
north america big cats though don't see
humans as food they run from them
even even mountain lions but
like i said if they start small they can
make it apart yeah because i've heard
about
you know like little kids getting lost
and getting jumped on by mountain lions
not so much grown people it does happen
but i think it's more common when it's
like a little kid
yeah that like kind of wandered away
from their parents and then a mountain
lion's like ooh snack
animals animals in north america tend to
judge you by how far
how far your eyes are off the ground so
if you stand
tall and your eyes are high off the
ground you're not food
the higher your your eyes are the more
likely you are that they
won't see you as food it's a strange
thing but it's just something that
they've noticed
also if you're not acting like a prey
well i think that kind of uh
that's kind of a factor as well people
are kind of overly worried about bears
here you know um
no black bears are almost totally
harmless i mean they they have been
they have eaten people in the past but
that's the individual behavior
of a certain black bear that had its own
personal history
it's not normal for black bears to eat
generally black bears are pretty chill
yeah generally unless you [ __ ] with
their
babies yeah no actually no not even a
black bear
black bear you know arrange your park
ranger or grab a black bears babies and
the [ __ ] mama just runs along and
where are you doing my cub they don't
attack why are you taking me why are you
taking where are you going
you can man handle a a black bear
they'll grab by the feet and pull them
out of them garbage cans
it depends on how big the bear is
they're in lucky what you know how rude
you are
if it has it out there's a lot of black
bears did not evolve to be
predators not the black bears they're
they
they evolved to run first ask questions
later
the brown bear grizz kodiak that's a
totally different ball
polar bear there he polar bears one of
the worst ones polar bear [ __ ] you up
they're
dangerous and they're dangerous because
they're very intelligent
and you're smaller than they are so they
just see you as food
especially if you had to handle yourself
wrong but that guy who made that
program proved that you can walk up to a
grizzly bear
you can walk up to him and befriend
grizzly bears until the one day when you
can until you run into the wrong grizzly
bear
he ran into the wrong grizzly bear one
day and he goes i don't like that bear
because if a bear ever eats me out here
it's gonna be that one because that
one's such a yeah i don't like the way
that bear
is i don't like the way he looks he says
that look on his head a month later that
bear ate
him yeah and and they captured it on
tape he was running the tape at the time
ate him and his girlfriend i would not
advise listening to that tape and at
least yeah
it's it was eating her alive and him
alive pretty horrible
yeah it's pretty horrifying and but
to defend what he was saying even though
he shouldn't have never been doing what
he was doing
he walked up and befriended
20 30 bears and remembered him
yeah and worked got a relationship with
him
you know and he knew which bears that he
could
interact with and ones that he couldn't
ones that were
didn't like him or ones that could pop
and the bear that ate him was a weak
and aging bear that wasn't eating
it's just kind of well it's just kind of
like people animals have their own
little personalities too at least like
you know higher mammals and stuff like
that
so it's like you can't across the board
say oh
you know bear's going to eat your bear
is not going to eat you well i was like
yeah maybe that particular bear would
eat you maybe most bears wouldn't eat
you
bears are pure emotion and they know
they understand only emotion and um you
know that's why a guy that
you know there's a guy who owns some of
them and he loves them you know and he
goes you're a good
bear he just keeps he just repeats
you're a good bear and that bear loves
that man and that's what keeps him from
getting gambling
yeah and that's what keeps him from
getting eaten
is that he constantly tells that bear
that he's a good bear don't ever tell
him he's a bad bad yeah
he's gonna knock your [ __ ] head off
but he's got a good relationship
they have the intelligence similar to a
chimpanzee actually
uh and a personality kind of like a dog
which that's
can be a very dangerous combination yeah
but like i said it just sometimes it
depends on the bear and sometimes it
depends on if you come out of wrong
yeah so she may have been um
depending on what what what animal
migration was at the time you know
granters is in there as a
grain warden he could he can back up
what i'm saying we both know
the field and and the local animals
around here depending on what animal
migration was
like at that time what the season was
like how hard of a season it was
she may have been eaten by a mountain
lion or a bear maybe but like i said i
mean it's winter it was december
it was like early december it was really
cold that's a good time to get eaten
well the bears would have been
hibernating that's what i'm saying
and the thing about it like amanda's
saying uh she's worked in multiple
national parks it's like mountain lions
get punished way too much they don't
generally like people and avoid them
i like i said if anybody that gets
attacked by
a mountain lion there would have to be
ex like strange circumstances normally
they wouldn't
this is also not present-day america
this is the 40s
that's true too which uh there were
areas that were more secluded back then
more in their natural state even in the
united states even though a lot of
people believe
city people whose feet never left the
[ __ ] pavement will sit around tell
you all day long what the [ __ ] nature
is like
they've never lived in it okay they have
this idea that there are places on the
united states
they have these places they have this
idea that every inch in the united
states is populated
and tamed [ __ ] i don't think anyone
has that idea well
they talk like that there are places in
[ __ ] washington state
that mankind has never set foot it's
just
it's just as much as canada there are
places in canada where man's never been
so and there are places in california on
the sierra nevada mountain range
where rarely a person has tread there's
a lot of places here that are just
well it's a big it's big area you look
at a map and you think oh there's not
much there now
that map does not illustrate the actual
size
you know uh void
now it is true
if you drop you can drop a man off
anywhere
in any location in the united states as
long as he picks a direction
and walks long enough eventually he'll
hit a road
if you can eventually okay if you can
make it that far
in the desert you probably wouldn't but
you know uh
you got your own whole other set of
problems she may have been you know
just this is just throwing this out
there she disappeared but this may have
been an animal attack
maybe or like i said could have been a
creepy person could have been more
likely a person
she probably either that or she wandered
off the trail i don't know because the
trail it was a pretty popular trail
um she wasn't really dressed for the
cold weather
so i feel like she wasn't really
planning on staying out that long
so i kind of feel like either somebody
snatched her or she got lost somehow
like she wandered off the trail or
something like maybe it started to snow
and she couldn't see the trail anymore
or something like that i don't know but
nobody knows what happened to her
and that was like way back in 1946 now
as i said the
uh her dad actually petitioned
uh or you know was like a lobbyist and
he he was the one that was kind of
instrumental in getting
uh vermont to you know pass a law saying
that they had a state police then so it
was actually that disappearance that
caused them to have that um and like i
said it still disappeared now as i
mentioned
her disappearance was i believe it was
the second one
in the five disappearances that happened
right in the same area and right around
the same time period
uh which caused one uh journalist
to dub the area the bennington triangle
much like the bermuda triangle because
they were
and these are weird because these
disappearances even though they're in
the same area
and within this time same five-year time
span um
they're otherwise kind of like unrelated
so it's like a really strange because
it's not a big
area so it's really weird that like
people would like five people would just
disappear like in a short time like this
so this was between 1945 and 1950 five
people like i said disappeared in the
same exact area including
paula gene weldon now interestingly so
this is centered around glastonbury
mountain in the towns like surrounding
it
now the first person to disappear and
this was about a year
uh before uh paula j weldon disappeared
was midi rivers he was this guy and he
disappeared
november 12 1945. he was 74 years old
and he was out hunting he was a very
avid hunter and fisherman whatever
he you know and he went out all the time
he was actually a guide
for a group of four hunters going up the
mountain on the way back
he got ahead of the group and when they
got to the point where they're supposed
to meet up with him
he was gone and was never seen again
the only uh the only clue to his
whereabouts that they found later on
when they searched
was a single rifle cartridge found in a
stream
now they thought maybe that he had
leaned over the stream and the cartridge
had dropped out of his pocket
it was on fire but as far as i know yeah
as far as i know they said rifle
cartridge not brass casing
yeah okay yeah he must have dropped it
yeah
but other than that they have found no
trace of him either
uh as i said he was an experienced
hunter and fisherman had lived in the
area all his life as far as i
can tell and uh you know so they never
found him either
um now the second person like i said was
paula jean weldon she disappeared in
december of 1946
the next person to disappear was james
tedford and this was in 1949.
this is december 1st 1949
so this is exactly three years after
paul weldon's disappearance
now he was actually living in the
bennington soldiers home
and he was in saint albans in vermont
visiting relatives
and was this one is really weird he was
coming home on the bus
and he disappeared off the bus somehow
so according to witnesses he got
appeared off the bus
he got listen to this [ __ ] it's like so
he gets on the bus yeah
and he was still on the bus at the last
stop right now the last stop and the bus
was gonna go to bennington but i guess
it made one stop before it went there
like that was it's you know the end of
the line or whatever
somewhere between the last stop and
bennington vermont
he disappeared all of his [ __ ] was still
on the bus like all of his luggage
and there was a timetable for the bus
like left open
on his seat but there was no trace of
him
at all it was like somebody like just
aliens
abducted him right off of the [ __ ]
bus that's some weird [ __ ] that kind of
reminds me that's pretty weird right
that reminds me when i was in boston
i got [ __ ] hammered one time at the
bar
and one got onto the red line was headed
back towards
um davis square because i had to get off
on that exit
they were called davis yeah david square
and somehow or another i fell asleep on
the damn train i hate when that happens
yeah i thought that happened a time or
two i fell asleep on it
when i woke up it wasn't moving and
everybody was gone
because you see it shuts down at like
two and a half yeah you feel like oh my
god
this is how horror movies start yeah
and i was at the end of the line and
they put the damn train up
they were like ah [ __ ] that guy no no no
no i was like what the [ __ ] well the
doors then opened
okay and i got up to get out and look
out and the [ __ ] the train
one of the train guys was walking
towards me and he goes oh you're up
and he says yeah we we didn't want to
wiggle you put the train up man you got
to come on out of there
because they saw me on the cameras right
because the trains got cameras in it
yeah
i was sleeping in that [ __ ] everybody
else got off i was sleeping
and i had to get out of [ __ ] the very
end of the line
and uh which was two or three stops away
from where i was supposed to get so i
had to walk i was drunk had to walk
walk extra so you had to stagger three
or four miles
to where davis and what did we learn
don't fall asleep i didn't learn [ __ ] i
didn't learn
[ __ ] because i [ __ ] because i did it
again guys no
i just didn't learn anything it's just
it was not a learning experience
because i was pretty hammered okay all
right
you know and i had whatever yeah and i
didn't want to spend the money to get a
cab
i don't blame you there was i was young
then you know money is harder harder to
come by
i had to walk like an extra three or
four miles
that sucks yeah oh well but it was
[ __ ] weird
to wake up at the end of the station and
it went in there yeah and it was like a
round because
the train comes down to one track and
then they have a place where they can
park all the trains right
and they were parking the ball and
evidently the guy that was [ __ ]
controlling that train i guess he
probably just the camera is funny
probably happens a lot well i'm sure it
does yeah but when the doors opened up
it woke me up
yeah i don't know tammy said i wonder
how many people thought you were dead
they didn't want to talk so i was
sitting up you were probably snoring
yeah
sitting up going yeah wearing golf
clothes
oh my god actually you should be glad
you're not a girl because that might
have ended very differently
just saying but yeah i don't i don't
think i've ever i've fallen asleep on
because i used to take the bus all the
time before i had a car
i think i've fallen asleep on the bus a
couple times just not from being drunk
just for being really tired and i missed
the stop but only by like one or two
and sometimes sometimes you'd have some
creeper following you and you'd have to
get off at a different stop so he didn't
know where you lived you had
you had to do that a few times as well
uh but yeah so this dude
apparently just disappeared off this
[ __ ] bus
and nobody knows where he is all his
stuff was still on the bus
and they would or he jumped out the
window but nobody knows anything nobody
said anything it's like you would think
that at least the driver would be like
yeah where the [ __ ] did he go jumped out
the window
maybe the only way he could have done it
that's so [ __ ] weird
must have been like a suicide baby
it just seems like if you're going to
commit suicide by jumping out of a bus
window which
okay random well why would you like take
any stuff with you then maybe or look at
the timetable you're reading too much
into it
maybe you know maybe jumping out the
window isn't how he committed suicide
he opened he he put the window down and
waited for him to go to a light
and then he jumped out and then the bus
left with all his stuff in there
and then he went off and [ __ ]
committed suicide
and you know i mean staging is a
disappearance basically
yeah kind of like the dude that staged
the ufo abduction well from the air from
the airplane he was flying
yeah remember that yeah yeah he's
calling in through the
to the tower saying the ufos behind him
you know it's got me i see the beam of
light and then you never heard it
yeah i was just like i was thinking
about that because i kept when i was
researching like different
disappearances
that dude's case kept coming yeah and
they found i think they found the plane
didn't they but they didn't find him i
don't know i have to look that up i
thought they found the plane eventually
it was over the water wasn't
if i'm remembering it right but like i
said i don't know i don't think he
abducted him i think he killed himself
but he didn't want his dad to
think that he killed he wanted people to
think that he people i think he wanted
people to remember him
and well so i think mission accomplished
engaging a ufo abduction
was was part of it well yeah that's a
lot more splashy than just like you know
hanging yourself or taking an overdose
or something yes i think yeah i mean i
guess if you're gonna do
like i'm not saying like you should but
if you're gonna do it at least like do
it in style yeah i think
well i think part of it is that he
didn't want his parents to think that he
killed himself
yeah that's i think although that said
and i think we've talked about this
before because i've kind of talked about
uh some people that killed themselves
especially back in victorian england for
whatever reason or early 20th century
england
by jumping in front of trains and i'm
always just kind of like
please please don't do that i mean it's
just kind of like one messy
somebody has to clean your splattered
carcass up off the [ __ ] it's like why
would you
and the dude that drove the train into
and couldn't stop
and all the people on the train are
gonna be like traumatized forever so why
would you want to do that to people
well one of my uh friends when i was in
boston
she lived next door to her and her
husband and she was a mental health
uh professional she took care of a bunch
of outpatients
and they were all medicated instead of
putting them in
into into institutions but she always
had several suicides a year
she said there were certain kinds of
them
that said when they usually committed
suicide they wanted it to be
as painful and as like yeah
okay and and and as splashy as possible
because one they feel that they have to
atone for some kind of
yeah they thought they deserved it sure
they did all right which is awesome a
lot of times this
a lot of times they've imagined what
they did
yeah it's not something that they
actually did [ __ ] they imagined that
they did
or sometimes they did do it but it
wasn't their fault
like one of those kind of things like
you know sexual abuse yeah you know what
i mean like
some chick would think that you know
she was responsible for her sexual abuse
well that's very common yeah
and you know because like it's like
might have been her dad you know
her dad told told her it was her fault
you know that kind of thing well yeah
that's what i mean that's that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you up forever
especially when it happens to you when
you're a kid she told me about that one
patient that she had and what that girl
did
is that she went into her bedroom with a
can of gasoline and poured it all over
herself and the bed and set
herself and the bed on fire and she was
alive for a long time
that's a rough way to go yeah and uh
i was like what you know i was
questioning it i was like why did you
just
kill herself but yeah yeah yeah you
tried to
burn burn away all the guilt and
everything you know so that's why and
that's so that's so [ __ ] shitty
because i feel like that happens so much
especially like
you know with girls that were sexually
abused when they were kids like by their
dads or whoever
um are family friends and
their whole life especially when it
happens to you when you're really young
like their whole life they're [ __ ] up
because they think that all that [ __ ] is
their fault and they just
do they just deserve to be treated like
[ __ ] oh yeah well the dude is doing it
too i don't know who it is but they do
the students are
telling them that right do it and it's
usually like a kid
so you know they just believe it to be
true
yeah because it's usually it's an
authority figure or a parent or whatever
yeah and when you're a kid you kind of
believe everything that authorities
figures tell you they use a bunch of
manipulation on them yeah you know what
i mean and you know if the girl starts
to enjoy it then they get even more
[ __ ]
guilty about it because they brainwash
them into thinking that they enjoy it
and this and that and they play all
kinds of games with their minds
well and they're growing up in all that
yeah and so when they
when they reach adulthood they're
they're kind of [ __ ] confused about
what was true and what was not true
and um instead of just trying to set it
down and realize none of that [ __ ] was
true
because you weren't in charge well the
shitty thing about it too is that i feel
like
sometimes abusers take advantage of that
because girls in particular and
you know women in particular yeah they
have a tendency if something goes wrong
to blame themselves they turn everything
you know in general they turn everything
internally yeah they don't say it's like
oh you know you [ __ ] up
they're like what did i i [ __ ] up i
must have done something wrong to
deserve this i must have done something
to deserve this
so i do kind of feel like abusers take
advantage of that
proclivity that is more uh common in
women i think that yeah and then when
like in that particular case i think i
think she said that girl was also
[ __ ] schizophrenic so
whether or not the abuse caused the
schizophrenia or the schizophrenia
allowed the abuse or it was just
a combination of a combination of a
bunch of problems happening
and you know what i mean some people
just are not really destined to live for
very long because you just got too many
goddamn problems
and a lot of them are not your fault but
they're not solvable either
you know um that's just the way it is
like it's just i know it's like it's
super
if i take a frog i can do all kinds of
weird [ __ ] to the frog and [ __ ] that
frog up is that that frog's fault no
is that frog [ __ ] up yeah is it fair
no
not at all life is not fair life is
[ __ ] extremely cruel
is that right no but well it's just it's
indifferent yes and different
you know life is not right matter of
fact you know
nietzsche and and schopenhauer would say
that the
ultimate form of wrongness is to exist
okay existence itself is wrong
so you know you shouldn't even be here
yeah you shouldn't be here right
so you know which you know i i like that
old philosophy but
you can't those [ __ ] were crazy
too i mean it was interesting [ __ ] that
they were all crazy but
they're all that was all mental
experiments that they were doing
on paper you know but uh you know like
the perfect state
even the buddhists believe the perfect
state
of existence was non-existence because
there's no way to impose on other
creatures
the fairest thing that could ever happen
is for you
not to exist because everything you are
was taken from something else
because your ass is in the [ __ ] way
yeah everything you have
could have could have could have
belonged to somebody else who really
needed it
you your existence in itself is imposing
on the universe
it's not fair that you live you know
that that's
that goes back to a lot of the [ __ ] you
hear these [ __ ] young kids saying to
get it not fair
yeah ain't fair life isn't about
fairness
if you really wanted fairness just kill
yourself
that's what the [ __ ] great scholars
were that's what the great philosophers
said
although none of them did though did
they no
[Laughter]
well legend has it siddhartha go to my
did
and they were like i will not take food
from this earth this is all you know i
don't deserve it
he's hardcore and then they're like uh
yeah but we're giving you food no no
this is food that should go to somebody
else
although even a real person i feel like
he was like some jesus christ
that's what i thought no i don't think
he would well they believe he was but i
don't think he ever
right but people believe jesus was a
real dude he was
he was a it's a demigod
basically yeah you're putting all of
your
buddha or your buddhistic ideals
okay yeah and could that person exist no
they would die
that's why in the story he does i can no
longer impose on this planet
stop feeding me i will just stop he's a
breatharian yes
i'm gonna go to a breatharianism he
thinks he can just live on air he
doesn't need any food or water
it's not just vegetarianism it's not
just veganism we're going to go to
breatharianism
where you don't even eat just breathe in
the air
that's where you get your hair yeah
that's where all my calories are coming
from solar power
and [ __ ] oxygen sure yeah when are
you going to be installing some solar
panels
solar panels solar panels yeah
did you guys see more damage yeah no one
knows what i'm talking about yeah
that's okay amanda said a true story at
one of my previous jobs we were stuck
there an extra 12 hours
while they cleaned up what was left of a
guy who left in front of a train
yeah see it's like i get it i get
that you want to punish yourself but man
don't punish other people like that i
just i couldn't bring myself to do that
i don't want somebody cleaning up after
me no that got to part two she said that
some of it
some of them when they committed suicide
it was to impose on other people
just on purpose i wanted to be dead it's
a [ __ ] you i'm gonna make you clear yeah
i see that
my make you clean i'm gonna make you see
this i'll make you clean this up you're
guilty you did this to me
it's that's that's what it is well yeah
i do because i know i'm not going to say
what his name is but
a friend of mine in high school yeah uh
several years later
uh committed suicide yeah and he very
it seemed very purposely yeah um wrapped
himself up in a blanket and shot himself
in the head so that all the
stuff would like just go all over the
blanket seven he wanted his dad to find
him like that
yeah because he did not like his dad
yeah
you did this to me and he knew that his
dad make you clean this up
i'm out of here that's that's the
thinking yeah look at what you did to me
it's all selfish [ __ ] when you really
think about it most of the time i mean
well it depends on what your reasons are
i know that a lot of people say oh
suicide selfish and stuff like that i
don't
i don't think it always is no it depends
on what your motivation
yourself to escape a fate worse than
death that's that's that's very
different
very different and like i said some
people suffering from certain men
mental illnesses depression um to them
being alive
yeah is a fate worse than that yeah so i
get that
and their judgment isn't sound anyway
they're they're malfunctioning
so you can't ascribe accurate
moral if you want to use moral systems
you can't really ascribe anything
[ __ ]
logical to it you know it's a person
being irrational
yeah which like i said i get that but
you know
all this i just feel like i don't know
it's just so weird i've done so many i
wrote about so many true crime cases
where
the aftermath of a lot of them was like
oh this dude was a suspect in the case
and he killed himself by jumping in
front of a train it's just it happened
so many times that i was just kind of
like what the [ __ ] man that was like a
trend
for jumping in front of a train like i
said don't do that nobody wants to clean
up after you
um but yeah so yeah so this guy
disappeared off the bus that's which is
how we got off on that whole tangent
nobody knows where he went i don't know
like i said it's really weird because
the driver you think that the driver
would be like yeah he was here and then
i turned around and he was gone i don't
know it's like
she just [ __ ] disappeared i don't
know the aliens took him i guess
so there was another person that
disappeared paul jefferson this was
actually a kid
this is an eight-year-old and he
disappeared october 12 1950
this was the same area the bennington
triangle
he uh was with his mom in a truck now
she got out of the truck and went over
to like feed the pigs or whatever
uh she was gone for an hour because i
guess there was a lot of pigs
and when she came back uh the sun was
gone
so either he got out of the truck and
wandered off or somebody snatched him
out of the truck
they uh formed a bunch of search parties
and looked for him but they never
ever found him apparently they did some
they had some bloodhounds that they
brought in they tracked the kid to a
local highway
and that was where they lost the trail
um and this highway might have been
right around the same area where apology
and weldon disappeared so like i said a
lot of uh
folk legends have sprung up about this
particular area in vermont
the fifth and last disappearance uh was
frida langer this was also 1950.
this was only a little over two weeks
after uh that little eight-year-old kid
had vanished
this was october 28 1950 frida langer
she was 53
and her and her cousin whose name was
herbert elsner
they were at a campsite near the
summerset reservoir and they were going
to go on a hike
now during the hike she slipped frida
slipped and
fell into a stream she wasn't hurt
really badly or anything but she told uh
herbert
she's like um hey it's like you know you
hang around we'll go back to the
i'll go back to the campsite change
clothes because she was all wet
and then i'll catch up to you now they
did that
but she never showed up so at this point
herbert goes back to the campsite and
sees that she hadn't
returned nobody had seen her since they
left over the next two weeks five
searches were conducted
aircraft helicopters 300 searchers hold
nine yards
um now this woman was unusual in the
bennington triangle because they did
eventually find her body
they found her several months later may
12 1951
her body was actually found near the
somerset reservoir um
this area had been extensively searched
seven months previously but they had not
found her
then but they did find her a little bit
later on however they could not
determine cause of death because
the remains were too decomposed so
as i said these five disappearances
during the short amount of time
in this very same area referred to as
the bennington triangle like i said
now the next couple cases i want to talk
about these are two
again that are kind of linked um
i don't know if i buy it but these two
were usually linked because they
happened right around the same area
where ed gein
lived and he was active at the time so
some people have speculated that maybe
one or both of these
uh both of these victims were a victim
of ed gein
i don't know if i buy it but like i said
um i think it's time for another drink
probably
are you ready you think you handle it
yeah well like i said it's going to be a
while before we go
it'll wear off yeah and it'll wear off
for them but this but the second one
will be the last one though
all right because like i said we don't
really want to be dry
yeah let me give you the same thing yeah
cause it's only six we're not leaving
for another like three hours
we're fine we're fine all right so the
next two
like i said these are the disappearances
of the two separate disappearances of
evelyn grace hartley and
georgia weckler these were both in
wisconsin
uh right in around the la crosse area so
evelyn
hartley she was actually this happened
in 1953.
so she was actually babysitting a 20
month old
toddler at the home of a
professor named viggo rasmussen which is
a fantastic name
he was a professor at la crosse state
college now
rasmussen and his wife um i guess the
night that this happened there was like
a big uh homecoming game
like big football so a whole bunch of
people in lacrosse
including the professor and his wife
were going to this game
now they had a regular babysitter like a
girl that came in babysat for their you
know
watch their kid but because the their
regular babysitter was also going to the
football game
they needed to get a replacement so they
got this girl evelyn hartley instead
now she okay so apparently so evelyn
shows up at the house
uh she was just gonna study the baby was
asleep you know it was a little
little kid and uh so she brought a bunch
of books with her she was just gonna
like sit and study
now she was supposed to call her parents
at 8 30 p.m to check in and tell them
that everything was okay
but she never called so
her dad just kept calling the house
because obviously they knew where she
was going
um but there was never any answer
so he started to get worried and goes
over to the rasmussen's house
to check on her now when he gets there
he finds that the house's uh doors are
all locked
the lights were on the radio was on the
baby
was uh still asleep in the crib totally
fine he was a little girl
however uh there was no sign of evelyn
there the only
um disturbance in the house was that the
furniture in the living room
was kind of all disarranged it says so
it was kind of all moved around
um evelyn's textbooks were kind of
scattered they were sort of
thrown about or knocked off the table
they found one of evelyn's shoes
and her glasses which were broken they
were on the living room floor
her other shoe was in the basement they
found that
so obviously they go down to the
basement
now all the windows on the upper portion
of the house were all locked
but there was a basement window at the
back of the house
and thank you
and the uh okay so the basement window
was on the back of the house
the screen on that window had been taken
out and was leaning against the outside
wall
try that now
yeah it's pretty good what's uh what is
it it's that strawberry with a pineapple
with
what do you call coconut yeah it's
pretty good pretty good
pretty good uh okay so
underneath this particular window which
was open
um was a short step ladder this
stepladder
belonged to the rasmussen family they'd
been painting the basement so i guess
that's why it was out
three of the other windows which were
still locked had primarks around them so
i guess somebody tried to get in there
like with a crowbar or whatever uh they
also found
uh some footprints from a pair of
sneakers in the basement window box
and in the living room now
in addition to these signs obviously
someone had broken into this house and
taken this girl
they also found um quite a bit of blood
this
this was uh 1953 so they couldn't do dna
obviously
but the blood type was the same as
evelyn's blood type they found it inside
the house near the basement window
and they found it outside in the yard
two of the pools
uh there were two pools of blood in the
yard one staying 18 inches
in diameter which is a lot of blood
that's pretty good so
that's that's yeah she was killed
probably but the house maybe very weird
that they took her with
them they wanted the body for whatever
reason
sex yeah some necker files maybe
that's pretty creepy though well maybe
that wasn't the original plan
the original plan was to get her out of
there live she struggled at the window
maybe so i mean it seemed like
whoever this was whether it was one
person or two people
um they obviously tried a bunch of
windows and they wouldn't open
and finally they found one that did open
use the step ladder came into the
basement and then they must have come up
to the living room
because all of her [ __ ] all of her books
and everything were kind of dumped off
the table oh was she again
um she was a teenager okay yeah
she was like you're not letting me yeah
you're not taking me out the house
i'm not leaving with you well yeah [ __ ]
i don't blame her she started fighting
back and killed her
yeah maybe so but like i said threw out
the window and then climbed out the
window and drug her out and [ __ ]
carried her off
yeah she's like she's still warm yeah
yeah it was like a ted bundy
[ __ ] yeah something like that
that's like oh well i can i can deal
with him alive or dead
everybody remember that about ted bundy
and every every time somebody says oh he
was so good looking yeah
he [ __ ] overheads so put makeup on
yeah and he kept him like on the [ __ ]
mantle and everything
and he'd like screw the heads and he
keep trying to keep him in the
refrigerator yeah he's chris
he's gross as [ __ ]
didn't wasn't he the mantle put her or
was that the other guy yeah he was a man
that's what i just said
he's a mantle mantle putter yeah is that
he's a mantle putter yeah
yeah let's keep that and then we can
just pull it down whenever we well
it's kind of like it's kind of like the
shoe fetish thing okay
i gotta shoot fetish but i gotta have
the woman
you know what i mean well yeah you don't
just want the shoes you don't want the
shoe without the dumb dudes that are so
bad they just want the shoe
well like there comes a point i guess
yeah you don't need one well it's all
it's all on a spectrum right because
like if you have a thing where it's like
oh i like
the way women's feet look in the shoe
wait it makes it eventually just one
notch
further than that it's like well i don't
even need the one that woman man just
get in the shoe
because they're you know they're always
bitching and like wanting things
having their own personalities and
whatnot i can't deal with that right so
i just want
to show you gotta take him out yeah
shoot his shoe is not
gonna answer you back she was good
enough but she's not gonna if she's good
enough just to shoot and then like
well that's that's what [ __ ] bundy
was all about you know what i mean
he liked head literally and he's like
well i don't really need a woman just
need the head
that's the only part of him that's any
good anymore well it's more portable
yeah yeah i mean a lot
like from a practical standpoint though
yeah that's absolutely a lot easier just
take the head
yeah there's a dead body in the bag and
then you [ __ ]
and then you can keep that in the
refrigerator and and so you know
one homicide will yield
maybe weeks of [ __ ] entertainment
until you get sick of that or it starts
it's too it's too it's too
it's not fresh anymore it's too rotten
not rotten but yeah it starts to spoil
so you go ah she's she's no good no i
need a new one i used her up
yeah she's got to go and then you know
it's like that
that's what he's doing yeah i'm just
thinking of all the
yeah washing it off in the sink yeah
that's what i was just thinking about
make the hair pretty again put makeup he
put makeup on it just like one of those
like
yeah remember when you were a little if
you were a little girl in the 70s you
had one of those like barbie
yeah makeup things and it was just like
the head well there was a little bit of
a neck too it wasn't like
it wasn't like horror movie [ __ ] right
but it was it was kind of had a tray and
then it came with all these little like
cosmetics and you could put that then
you could fix her hair and [ __ ] you got
the sensation of presence
you know the sensation that she's there
you know
some weird [ __ ] very weird [ __ ]
that's some perversion there no you
don't say that's a perversion there
god damn i'm so glad that fucker's dead
yeah [ __ ] creep
and he got away with so much because he
was like normal looking
yeah i didn't want to say good luck and
he wasn't but he was just like normal
he didn't look like he don't get a
threat he didn't look like a serial
killer
he didn't but a lot of them don't well
yeah none of them really look like a
serial killer but most of them look like
worms
i've seen the people that i thought that
looked like a serial killer
gary ridgeway didn't look like a serial
killer he just looked like a worm
he looked like some dude that you worked
with and he's just like a non-entity
you know i mean somebody that you
wouldn't notice your eyes are glad
now if you'd had a damn personality
maybe he you
you know what i mean you'd be like yeah
yeah i like that guy he's cool
but no gary whisperer didn't have a
[ __ ] personality at all
you just didn't have one well and we've
talked about this lots of times because
i feel like especially dudes
in the you know in cell community he
wasn't on sale though he was married no
i'm just saying that
yeah what i was going to say was that a
lot of dudes that are kind of into that
kind of [ __ ] are always
like oh women they're so shallow and
they just want you know if you're ugly
or you don't have money or something
like that and i'm like that's a bunch of
[ __ ]
all you need to you have you need to
have a good personality well there's a
lot of [ __ ] involved
i've looked at the so-called in-cell
[ __ ] uh
phenomenon and it's kind of blown out of
proportion yeah you did have some dudes
that
could kind of fit that um
description who say like did mass
shootings and stuff you know like that
one guy
you know i mean but those guys are very
rare and most
it in cells are not like that um
especially especially if you know
[ __ ]
um anglo-american type in cells most of
them are
they're not a threat they get online
they took a lot of [ __ ]
the thing is about their the problem
with with most of them is their thinking
don't give me a chance dr ms andre
all right the they talk about how women
are shallow and they're only after them
for their [ __ ] money they're only
like into men you know they only want
men for their money and their looks and
they're already looking for chad and
this and that
look man you got to turn that [ __ ] back
in on yourself and go look at yourself
they never do that though the women that
you're looking at are the [ __ ] top
echelon [ __ ] women
okay they're gonna go for top echelon
guys guys that
have a lot to offer all right what can
you offer that woman
yeah they never ask themselves that
question though and it's because it
requires effort
but they never seem to require any
effort they don't go on a diet they
don't go
they don't [ __ ] go to the gym they
don't do self-development
they don't [ __ ] oh well they don't
have anything they don't try to improve
themselves right they don't
they don't go out and have adventures
and build character
they don't do the [ __ ] they don't ever
[ __ ] even pursue a [ __ ]
career you know what i mean what are you
gonna offer this yeah just do something
that makes you interested yeah
you know that's all you have to do so
they never but then they want a top
echelon woman
well they want all they want everything
without having to do that
right that's the problem that's
entitlement that's entitled
i want you to look like this and that
and you want to love me and i look at
you and say dude man you're [ __ ] 60
pounds overweight
you can't you can't impose all of these
you know restrictions on people you're
going to oh they have to be a [ __ ]
kid
when you look like that or it doesn't
even matter if you
it's like that you're not even making an
effort not making an effort to like
be like cool like a cool person yeah now
that i don't
now that one dude who was weird as [ __ ]
who elliot roger
yeah i i would say okay now look you
guys always want to talk about mini me
minnie me was looked like that kind of
the one that happened yeah a little bit
yeah he was a little he was that size
and that build
yeah yeah and that he didn't have a face
like that but he was
at that level but he had a lot he had a
lot more outgoing personality but he had
a lot of weird quirks to him
yeah quirky he's the nicest way yeah
he's quirky
he was cool at first but then the more
you got to know him the more it was just
too god damn much
he was a little um he thought he was
grasping
yeah he he he thought you owed him
something all the time
yeah yeah like i said that's a problem
and and honestly like he didn't have a
lot of problems that
you know some people have like he
actually had a job he had a lot of
girlfriends
he had lots of girlfriends he's a you
know decent looking dude dressed nice
yeah um stuff like that yeah he you know
so he had a lot going on so he wasn't
like a loser he was just weird
yeah he was just a little weird we're
where we were and he was just like kind
of a lot to put up with because he was
like real spazzy
yeah so like he was like right for old
people like me it was like kind of
retiring to me
but the problem the problem with elliot
rogers
all right and the whole incel thing
first of all elliot rodgers wasn't a
common in cell
elliot rodgers was mentally
oh [ __ ] ill you could i could tell
just by the yeah big time
i could just tell by what he was saying
he was mentally ill
he had a manifesto anybody that had the
manifesto
run as far as you can away from that
person
i think he had some kind of some kind of
a weird form of autism
that's what it seemed like it was like
sexual autism
sexual art that's not my point it's like
sexual chocolate
sexual art is affectionate all right he
he
did all the things you were kind of
supposed to
do well i think that was but it was like
a robot doing it
yeah it wasn't like a real person it was
very robotic
and he didn't really have a character
he was pretending to have a character
or not even really pretending to have a
character he was pretending to be an
attractive guy
he was yeah that's a good way of putting
it because he did like a look i have
well and i think he even said that like
in the video where he was just like look
i have really nice clothes i have a
really expensive car i have this that
and the other thing and girls still
don't like me
and i'm like that should have told you
something right there
that there's something else the matter
with you right
most most in cells are not like that
most in-cells just make no effort
that's most of them but they want
everybody else to make everything
but they don't have it another version
of incels is that they
come from a certain part of a world
where women are off limits to them
they only women only go to the high
echelon men of course we're talking
about the middle east where
some dudes can have two three wives and
you know
it's always you know the top the top
thirty percent of women are all
always in every society running to the
top [ __ ] ten percent of the guys
so these in-cell dudes
ignore all ugly women they just ignore
them they're only looking at the hot
ones
those hot ones are all taken well that's
what i'm saying yeah
the thing about it is that you know you
they could probably find if they just
acted
for five seconds they could get a person
you could find a girlfriend you could
yeah it's like yes she might not look
like a [ __ ] supermodel right you
could find you can find a good one
but you know yeah yeah she might be
totally out and also you got to ask
yourself what is good
if she's good to you she's nice to you
she helps you out you have a good
relationship whether
you she's she you can have sex with her
in other words there's enough attraction
to where you can
you can have sex you know what i mean
just worry about that
i mean that's what most people most
people are doing are doing
don't worry about these [ __ ] women
that you're seeing
in these [ __ ] porn videos or these
[ __ ] chicks on [ __ ] instagram who
are making money as
instagram models they got thousands of
dudes [ __ ] competing with that
you think you're going to be able to get
that no no
no not by living in your mom's basement
[ __ ] 40 pounds overweight no job no
and like you said it's nothing to do
with like being fair or anything like
that
it's just biology yeah this is by well
you know jenny went out with me and [ __ ]
wasn't fair
she said he's different than these other
guys is that fair no it's not fair i was
taking an advantage
you were taking it was taking advantage
that's the strategy
i'm gonna [ __ ] dress better and dad's
better and [ __ ] you know what i mean
and i'm a good dude and i'm gonna
[ __ ] have friends with all these
people and everybody's you know this and
that
and and i never tried to [ __ ] go pick
up women
it just happened yeah you never really
had to try to because
well the thing about it that i think a
lot of people like about you yeah
you know is that i don't really care i'm
just having fun with people
well and you had a lot of female friends
yeah
and you were not banging that no no
and you were not really you just thought
they were cool they were they're people
and you just hung out with yeah they're
people and you weren't trying to get in
their pants
and i think that a lot of women
appreciate it yeah but the thing is is
that you know i
i like i like beautiful women especially
yeah especially if they're cool
but a beautiful woman if she's if she if
she's [ __ ] crazy
you're like you know who i'm talking
about well i've dated some of them
they're crazy they don't last long
you're like
i know exactly i know a couple people
you're talking about yeah
you're kind of a piece of [ __ ] and and
look
straight up honesty to you young guys
who might be listening to me
i got pictures to prove it i [ __ ]
been with the best looking ones [ __ ]
ever
especially when i was even younger okay
[ __ ] uh
tens twelves no no no twelves all right
fifteens two twenty
two hundreds yeah yeah i really didn't
[ __ ] there was no way
i wasn't even good looking enough for
them and they were just that's how good
looking they were right
especially in brazil and stuff um
a lot of times the better looking they
are the more of a piece of [ __ ] they are
not like a lot of times because they
yeah skate on their looks well yeah they
skate
i mean i'm not gonna say because like i
said generalizations are always kind of
very much
but very much so um you know that laura
is gorgeous and she's cool as [ __ ]
yeah and it looks like so i have met a
lot of
yeah i mean just amazingly beautiful
women
yeah that were just like the most
awesome yeah yeah and it's like not even
fair they're out there
i know a lot of women like that most of
my female friends are like that
our friend laura and i got pictures to
prove
and i've been friends with laura for
[ __ ] 10 years all right
laura looks like [ __ ] wonder woman
she makes me cry how pretty she's yeah
all right
[Laughter]
she's cool she is just ridiculous and
she is the coolest
sweetest yeah there is not there is not
a [ __ ] bone in her body
at all and she is just like the sweetest
person yeah and super
uh honest honest and just like yeah
she's awesome like a good person
me and her and jen went and had a coffee
right not too long ago a couple months
ago
but yeah she's like the coolest person
so don't think yes there is some truth
to you know that like
joke chart that people made where it's
like the hot crazy continuum
yeah that's only a certain time um which
to some extent
yes um because like i said the hotter a
girl is usually she can get by
on her looks but that's not always the
case that's not always the case
there's jen and laura and jan
we're going to go see we'll see them
tonight that's laura i don't think laura
is coming out but
yeah all right i got pictures to prove
that [ __ ]
that girl is such a good person i mean
you know what i mean she's
real genuine and real trustworthy and
just heart of gold
just a very good person so you can't use
bro logic
like oh she's a you know oh you know you
can't trust her you know it's not like
yeah it's like oh she's so pretty she
must be yeah she should be like no no no
it's not like that at all it's not like
that at all you know like i said you
have to take each person as an
individual it's not kind of like
yeah you can make certain
generalizations but yeah
uh you know up to a certain extent but
after a certain time it's like
generalizations kind of break down
because everybody's an individual
obviously
um you know like i said and honestly
i can't even think of any because i you
know i have a lot of female friends i
have a lot of male friends but
my female friends are they're all
gorgeous
yeah and all of them are awesome people
or i wouldn't be friends with them
right because you know i have some uh
enemies that are also gorgeous people
that are terrible kendra
she goes that's rose the hat yes that is
frozen that's what we thought when we
saw
we thought it was like oh my god it's
laura said it looks like laura because
she had a hat
she has a hat just like that yeah she
she had a hat like that before that
[ __ ]
before the movie came out he looked just
like what we saw in the theater that was
we both like turned to each other and
said oh my god laura
yeah yeah look just like her she's she's
not evil though
laura's not evil yeah she
she's actually a really rad person she
just like she messaged me the other day
but
she said she's gonna be coming back out
but it's gonna be a little while
but jen will be out tonight though yeah
because demetri is djing the vampire
ball
um you know among other people
[Laughter]
filthy guard so tom once dated pamela
anderson for real just trust me
okay i yeah my first wife
was [ __ ] built like that and she
looked [ __ ] great yeah
bit the big bolt-ons and everything the
bolt-on the big bolt-ons yeah
and that was like that makes me feel
like frankenhooker
no i don't know but when you call it
bolt-ons it means
i'm just like oh having this you don't
have bolt-ons
a bolt-on a book okay no i i didn't get
it
you have implants but it's more like an
internal you had big boobs before i did
yeah
a bolt-on is when you get a [ __ ]
100-pound girl 110-pound girl who's
[ __ ] got no body fat
and you put giant [ __ ] implants in
her
and they just look like spheres and you
can tell that they were just kind of
bolted on to it they're not natural it
gives you that [ __ ]
fake bimbo look which is it's sexy it's
it's a fetish kind of cake to it and pam
anderson made that look
kind of popular because there's no way a
woman of that [ __ ] body
would have would have boobs like that of
that shape
that's totally impossible totally
impossible
but the fakeness is what kind of gives
that look it's beauty is not natural
beauty is artificial it's okay tell me
about it it's always been body
modification
putting bowls in your lips earrings
stretching out [ __ ] earlobes to put
big rings in it
it's tattoos uh [ __ ] you know what i
mean tribal people and we're still
tribal
admitted or not we're still tribal
tribal people have always done body
modifications
to achieve beauty every culture
foot binding would you break a damn
girl's foot folded under make a little
tiny foot out of
ridiculous [ __ ] [ __ ] can't even walk
but
a guy will [ __ ] [ __ ] can't even walk
[ __ ] can't walk but a dude will [ __ ]
spend all of his [ __ ] gold
to keep man stable just because a little
bitty foot it's ridiculous
i have tiny feet and they're natural
natural chinese
yeah okay but the [ __ ] [ __ ]
restaurants
i know i've seen those shoes like in
museums i've seen the pictures yeah
it's because the toes are all folded
under because they they wrap them
and your foot just sticks like that so
it's like a little pointy
you have like one little pointy toe in
the front like
yeah it's [ __ ] up and like you said
they can't really walk
they they can sort of but they sort of
hobble yeah
you know what i mean so my people tattoo
their faces we don't know what your
people are though
must be more or nobody they call them uh
maori
yeah maybe that's the time to fish i
mean more than one does that but that
was the first thing i thought of
somebody's i mean yeah they said tom's a
man all young guys should aspire to be
him a man
don't [ __ ] tell them that because
[ __ ] my life wasn't perfect man
nobody's perfect
everybody just got a lot of trouble do
your own did a lot of stuff do your own
[ __ ]
and paid heavy prices for don't follow
anybody it's a heavy price to your top
it's a [ __ ] heavy price to be tall
but now it's about
me playing the world's smallest violin
yeah yeah yeah but now
now i'm bringing this all to y'all if i
can make on the show
[Laughter]
did you know you know if stallone lives
down here man i'm gonna run into
stallone i'm gonna do a video with still
on
you gonna run into him at starbucks one
day he's gonna be around here one of
these days
he lives around here having a deadly
everybody does
no word where it is he lives off of
[ __ ] markham
woods road well a lot of people do so so
that's just right here
i'm if i see stallone i'm gonna [ __ ]
jump out and [ __ ] take a video with
him
he's got several houses here i'm sure
he'll be what's that
yeah i'm sure he'll be thrilled
i'm your biggest fan no i ain't just
that
yeah you will i'm not a fan you're not
gonna like fangirl i'm a dude i'm a dude
i'm not a fan he's gonna be all cool i
can't wait to go out tonight i'm [ __ ]
sick of this [ __ ] man
i haven't even like gone to my [ __ ]
chat and honestly it's only like
dude it's not even it's 6 30. i don't
know we don't have to leave for like two
and a half hours our chest is feeling
good
i had my injection this morning i just
injected him yeah starting to come in
this is why he's getting
all yeah i'll head up a bit i need to
hit
something hit something i'm gonna hear
something tonight
not on the show this is live we're gonna
get demonetized we're gonna monetize
this
we're gonna open up our only fans
oh my god you're gonna have to pay 500
to get into early fans
no we're not gonna stop it's pulling me
it's pulling me down that direction down
around doing it we've thought about
doing that before but i'm just kind of
that was a long time ago now
i don't know i think i'd be too
self-conscious you know
i could i could i could cure that i
could
i don't know it wouldn't be live we
didn't get edited
even so it's like even if i edit it
well you know how it said you know and
somebody was saying that earlier it's
like women are very like critical of
themselves yeah they worry too much
they worry about the wrong things like
you know i mean it's never mind i don't
want to get involved in it because then
it'll start a fight
because they're critical of themselves
but they're
critical about the crit when they get
critical about themselves they're
actually critical about a feature that
guys would tend to like
but then they totally blissfully unaware
of certain things that
guys tend not to like because you know
uh
female beauty is is perceived very
differently from the eyes of
of guys than it is women you know what
i'm done and it goes the same way with
men
you know what i mean yeah what men a lot
of times aspire to and what they [ __ ]
think is cool is it man i'd like to do
what that guy's doing i like to
like to have that arm that that guy has
or that dude's shoulders man i want to
build a shoulder like that
women don't even get [ __ ] about that not
usually though no
i mean depends on like i said i don't
like to make generalizations but
yeah you know yeah it depends on the
women i think certain women have to have
it that way they do
but i think like i said and again i'm
generalizing but again
a lot of women are like they're kind of
more worried about
what you're like as a person well that's
to for granted i take that for granted
you have to be yeah
you know what i mean you have to be like
is that a cool person like i said you
could be the hottest [ __ ] in the world
but if you're an [ __ ] then yeah but
the pyramids upside down
you have to start off being cool then
what you look like is what you're
adding on top of that well yeah that's a
lot you have to be cool that's like
that's like a basis that's the baseline
but you see a lot of times there's a lot
of these dudes that get into fitness and
[ __ ] and sports
they weren't even cool well they're
compensating yeah they weren't cool to
begin with so then they start doing
weird [ __ ] they start getting stronger
and faster
they look great but as soon as you open
their mouth you're like man you're a
[ __ ] dish yeah bye-bye
but they weren't all like that i hooked
up remember i've told stories that says
yeah
grandparents was on here we were talking
about grandparents was
we were talking about back in the day
you know and jocks and [ __ ]
and i said yeah remember how [ __ ]
mccormick was yeah we didn't really hang
i didn't really hang out with jax but i
liked [ __ ] mccormick he was
a hockey player all right
and i liked him you couldn't consider
him a joke but he was very open-minded
and he
uh was [ __ ] a big good-looking guy
and [ __ ] would hang out with [ __ ]
like the punk rock girls that you know
and the girls that liked [ __ ]
you know uh early you know goth and
stuff and you know he smoked a little
bit of weed and [ __ ] at the campfires
and [ __ ] like yeah just
just like everybody else and and the
average
jock when we were in high school
couldn't do that they were too mentally
limited yeah tell me about but [ __ ]
mccormick
was cool he was just a cool dude i liked
him i knew some like sort of jock
adjacent people that were cool
but in in the main i was not a big fan
of jackson school because
for exactly the reason that you just
said yeah they weren't all like that so
i didn't really have yeah they weren't i
knew i
had differences i didn't really have
that bad taste in my mouth because
uh because we did hang out with some
cool ones yeah
yeah and then the ones that were
[ __ ]
though from that scene were the betas of
that scene they weren't the alphas they
were the betas
well because they had something to lose
they were trying to try to impress and
overcompensate [ __ ] that was the betas
overcompensation that's always a [ __ ]
you gotta watch out for that
let's get back to the show man 61 people
in there watching we've got a good we're
having a good response
yeah there we go dario says the heroine
just kicked in
go ahead damn
all right well you'll probably be a
dario says big feet on women i love it
you love brazil man you'd like [ __ ]
brazil
uh [ __ ] pravish which is [ __ ]
transsexuals okay because the only way
you could tell them apart from a woman
is first of all
back in these back in those days me
growing up there
if she was too [ __ ] pretty she was
probably transsexual
and and you had to check you had to look
down at the feet if the feet were big
you go yeah
yeah that's that's a that we would say
you didn't you didn't check the adam's
apple
no because they a lot of times they
didn't go through male puberties they
didn't have that
okay because they were taking hormones
before puberty
to transform it or so they didn't have
atoms of apple the only thing you could
tell is that their feet tended to be a
little bit bigger than
than say what do you call a what would
they kid we would call say a guy's foot
but nowadays again it's got to be a
biological male
yeah if they were born a biological male
they
their feet were going to be a little bit
bigger than a biological although i've
known some
women with some big-ass feet yeah that
too that too but
that's i i don't think that the only way
you were really going to know is reach
down
grab that's what i'm saying okay it was
going to be too late if you did that
i've told many [ __ ] stories and if
you've got and if you haven't got to the
point where you're like grabbing
somebody yeah
it's too late you're going to eat look
you're doing it whether you want to or
not
it's going to be [ __ ] very rude
and if you got if y'all don't believe me
[ __ ] i'll pull up i got pictures to
prove that [ __ ] just look
up [ __ ] a bruno butterfly and that's one
of the new they looked like that
all right they didn't look like
transsexuals they look like girls
all right trying to get me to [ __ ]
prove [ __ ] you don't really see this in
the united states too much but
in the time that i was there in the 80s
the number one top super
model was a woman named roberta claussi
or roberta close c-l-o-s-s-e was i have
a spell
roberta clausie a hoberto was her name
and she was a supermodel she was she was
um
biologically male okay but so that's
just been going on
since the [ __ ] 70s yeah i'm gonna
show you her
jen says hey is a bio girl with size 11
feet
that's what i mean i've not have no girl
with like
oh my god oh my goodness spooky spooky
stop
i wear a size six or seven depends on
the shoe
my feet are like small but they're wide
so i always have to get like those
like size six but wide i have to get
those
okay which is dumb because i have like
big huge fat legs but then like tiny
tiny feet at the bottom
here is roberta
back when i was there in the 80s okay
oh my goodness the string of pearls if
you saw somebody who was that pretty it
was probably a biological wheel
okay now
just walking around hold on one second
i'm going to show you i'm going to show
you
what it's like now
what is your deal pookie yeah
why are you yelling she's talking
she's like me she probably wants to go
outside
sit in the picture on a butterfly let me
see
see tarantino loves ladyfeet he does
he has a foot fetish he loves all the
feet in the movies
i didn't like notice it until i until
recently
okay that was very common there
it's all good we're all humans yeah
don't worry about it
[Laughter]
well it's a very macho culture
uh being gay was like second tier he
didn't really want to be gay
so if you were gay the better option
would be become female
ever does she have her clothes on i call
him her clothes
that's her collar she has to put the
collar on or she's going to go sit on
the porch i don't want somebody
kidnapping her but yeah i call them her
clothes though
all right so uh i don't even remember
where i was okay so we're
still talking about uh this girl that
got abducted while she was
babysitting which like i said it sounds
like a [ __ ] horror movie which maybe
i kind of feel like maybe some of these
horror movies about babysitter [ __ ] was
maybe based on something like this
because this happened in the 50s
so she so basically she's in the house
studying the baby is sleeping upstairs
the baby's fine
was still asleep didn't wake up during
this whole ordeal whatever it was
somebody or somebody's came into the
basement window came up to the living
room
and dragged this girl out of the house
through the window apparently there's
blood everywhere
so they got some bloodhounds they uh
traced evil and scent for two blocks
and then they lost the trail you know a
couple blocks away
uh so they imagined that you know she
probably got put in a car
at this point so when the police came
and they kind of like
you know canvas neighborhood or whatever
one neighbor said uh i saw light-colored
cars circling the neighborhood
about 8pm um another person that lived
in the neighborhood said they heard
screaming about 7pm but didn't really
think that much of it because they just
thought it was kids playing
obviously you wouldn't think about it
until later so they think that
sometime around 7 7 30 was when evelyn
was abducted
now two days after she disappeared
another dude that lived in the
neighborhood his name was ed hofer now
he came forward
and he said that about 7 15 that night
he almost hit a two-toned green
1941 or 1942 buick which was speeding
uh in a westward direction he said that
he saw two men and a girl inside
one of the dudes was driving the other
was in the back seat with the girl the
girl was slumped forward with her head
leaning against the front seat which he
thought was unusual which is why he
noticed it
now he said that even before he saw the
car
he'd seen the two guys and her
kind of staggering down the street near
where they later found some of the blood
now he didn't think anything about it at
the time because he said oh well maybe
you know they're drunk or something else
and they're going to the homecoming game
which pretty much everyone in town was
which
you know that's where he was going at
the time too so we didn't think anything
weird about
it um and obviously at the time that it
happened nobody knew that this
girl that had been babysitting was being
kidnapped so you know
um this dude i don't think they even
like released his name until like 50
years later so they didn't know he was
just like a witness but
now they know what his name is now a
couple days
after evelyn disappeared they found
a pair of underwear and a bra
uh that might have been hers they're not
entirely sure they found them near the
underpass on highway 14 about two miles
south of la crosse wisconsin
these were also stained with blood now
about four miles away they also found a
blood-stained pair of men's pants
on the same road but they don't know if
this is connected to the case or not
they also found a pair of size 11 blood
stained
good rich sneakers in the [ __ ] valley
area southeast of la crosse wisconsin
these were apparently dumped there only
a short time before they were discovered
now the souls of them had a um
had a pattern that was very similar to
the footprints that have been found in
the house where evelyn had been abducted
from
and the blood that was found on the
shoes was also the same type as hers
so they think that maybe these shoes had
been worn by
one of her abductors um inside
one of the shoes they found a single
human hair
they couldn't determine much about the
person that it possibly could have been
an african-american
man but they're not entirely sure so it
was inconclusive the test
they uh so authorities consulted
consulted the goodrich company
uh and said that this particular like
style of shoe was called
hood mogul which what the [ __ ] kind of
name is that i don't know she wouldn't
go outside it's the 50s
oh she just wanted to [ __ ] she went to
one door and then the other door and
then went back no
it changed my mind yeah yeah she went to
three doors
and said no to each one i think she
thinks that every single door leads to a
different difference
yeah so she's like well i don't like
this outside let's try this otherwise
no this is not working for me yeah
temperature isn't right on this one
let's go the other one yeah it's exactly
what she's doing also i think that she
thinks that we control the
weather yeah she's like turn it down
it's like it's too hot out
what are you why are you guys doing this
to me i don't understand
humans make it colder
i get it pookie i get it we can't do
anything about it though i'm sorry
but yeah so uh so this shoe which like i
said this is the 1950s
so shoe is called hood mogul which i
don't know that that just sounds very
funny to me
particularly in the 1950s so this
particular
shoe was sold in wisconsin obviously
iowa michigan minnesota and illinois now
they think that
whoever owned this pair of shoes was
like probably worked in a factory was a
mechanic or worked with some type of
machinery something like that
um also this is very specific
but they said that the pattern of wear
on the shoes suggested
that the person that wore them
frequently operated a whizzer
motorbike i guess because of the way
that the shoes and maybe on the pigs or
whatever
i don't know how they could determine
that 1953 but they're
apparently pretty sure about it another
weird thing is that they thought that
maybe two different people had worn
these shoes
because the wear patterns were like kind
of different like they're because they
thought because of witness statements
that it was it had probably been two
abductors
um because uh somebody saw like a car
with two dudes in it with the girl that
they think was her
so maybe this other person wore these
other shoes and they weren't the right
size like the shoes were too big for him
you know what i mean so they think that
that happened too i don't know why this
dude switched
shoes with the other kidnapper whatever
within 800 feet of the shoes they found
a well-worn size 36 blue denim jacket
with metallic buttons and blood stains
on the front back and sleeves
the jacket also had some base metal
paint flex on it
again you know probably this person
worked with some machinery worked in
some kind of mechanic shop or something
the jacket had been cut off at the
bottom
and roughly re-hemmed with white thread
one of the button
one of the four buttons was missing
there was a warm mark running the entire
width of the jacket under the armpits
possibly from a safety harness
which they thought was kind of
interesting they also found some fibers
like those that were that come out of
the of a scrub brush
they found those in the pocket now the
blood on the jacket was
evelyn's uh blood type and the blood
smears found at the house she was taken
from
were made by cloth with the
characteristics of denim so somebody
thinks that maybe
she had blood in the house and somebody
used the jacket to like maybe wipe some
[ __ ] up
or something like that um so
the jacket though was too small they
thought for somebody that was wearing
some size 11 shoes because they thought
that was probably a bigger person
uh so they think this is this was it i
had to look this up it says one
investigator concluded based on the
pattern of wear on the jacket the way it
was cut off
that whoever owned it worked as a
steeplejack and i was like what the [ __ ]
i've heard that word before but i didn't
know what it was i was like what the
[ __ ] is a steeple jack
a siebel jack is a person who climbs
tall structures
such as chimneys and steeples in order
to carry out repairs
so they think that whoever did it worked
a job like that because that was the way
they cut their jacket i guess
to make things easier to climb up of
things i don't know
so this particular kidnapping sparked
one of the largest searches in wisconsin
history so they did mass searches of
local vehicles lie detector tests to all
the students and teachers at evelyn
school because like i said she was a
teenager
they took the shoes in the jacket to 31
different towns around the area
displayed them to an estimated 10
000 people but nobody recognized them
and they had a bunch of suspects
questions over the years no
evidence to implicate anyone now some
people as i mentioned earlier
have suggested that maybe ed gein was
responsible for this [ __ ]
although i have to say this doesn't
entirely sound like his mo
he was active in this area in this time
period
but and yeah he did kill two women
but his deal was mostly one the two
women he killed
middle-aged women like you know bar
owners tavern keepers
most of the [ __ ] he did grave robin you
know
um so i don't know i'm not saying that
ed gaine didn't do this [ __ ]
uh because he was kind of active in the
area but this really doesn't sound like
something that he would do but i'm just
saying there was another one that
happened
a little bit later in the same area and
some people attribute that to ad gain as
well
um and the thing about ed gaine was that
when evelyn
was kidnapped ed gaine was visiting
relatives and he was only a couple
blocks away
from her so that's why people are
thinking about that you know yeah what
nothing
oh okay i thought you looked like you
were gonna like start no i'm not saying
anything pontificating about something
about some well you know if you want to
all right
daario is going that looks like a girl
we're talking about those you know uh
bruno
all right well yeah that's kind of i
just find that [ __ ] [ __ ] funny what
you have here in the united states with
all these people going on about
trans rights and all this [ __ ] these
are mostly people that are not trans
these are kids and these [ __ ] up
american kids
talk about trans rights and i just
[ __ ] laugh at this [ __ ]
okay because trans in brazil didn't need
rights they had [ __ ]
privileges they just did those girls
there that looked like that
okay dudes were fighting to get to those
they didn't want equality with women
they were they had a [ __ ] specialty
a niche you know what i mean being what
they were there's a special kind of guy
trying to get to that they only ended up
with [ __ ] rich dudes
you know what i mean it's not like they
were unpopular
so i just think that shit's funny you
know what i mean
that they need to have some kind of
special protection it's just it's not
the way it was
not in brazil they were like geisha
no carpet
well no if you went up there and says
you know well they were gone that's a
woman that's a woman
they wouldn't want to hear that they
were like no i'm trans
because if they were women then they'd
lose all their fans
you know what i mean they were that was
a that was they were a lot more rare
than a woman
it's i guess it's just a cultural
difference yeah that's exactly yeah i
mean so
it's just i just think this shit's
hilarious brazil's [ __ ]
was like 40 years ahead of all that
they they don't have any issues like
like that you know
all right so where was i okay so like i
said i don't know
i don't know i don't think edgine had
anything to do with this they did
question him
uh about uh you know the the barmaid
that disappeared that he did actually
end up killing
and that's when they found like all the
[ __ ] leatherface [ __ ] around his
house like i said leatherface was based
on him in case you didn't know that
um but like i said this climbing in
someone's basement window
kidnapping them leaving blood all over
the yard
doesn't really sound like his thing but
i'm not saying but you know maybe he was
branching out i don't know but that's
you know now he uh was uh if you didn't
know was declared insane we did a show
about him i think
and he died in a mental institution in
1984. they did like search all his
property and anything but
you know obviously they didn't find any
trace of evelyn
and he said that he was not involved now
he's
also uh kind of thought about as a
suspect in another
uh abduction in the same area and this
happened in 1947 and this was the
abduction of georgia
weckler now georgia weckler
was actually a little girl she was not a
teenager
she was last seen near her farm home in
rural fort atkinson wisconsin at about 3
30 p.m on may 1st 1947.
now what ended up happening thank you
victor jenny said
jenny ten out of ten tonight well thank
you very much i'm real i'm digging this
wig
it is kind of like going into my
lipstick though so that's why you see me
doing that because every now and then i
get like this little string
goes into my goes into my lipstick and
sticks and it's like annoying
johnny that girly [ __ ] looks good on you
it does but like i said sometimes when
i'm doing the show i just want to not
have hair like sticking in my lipstick
when i'm trying to talk but you know
what i mean
that's all that's a price you have to
pay to be pretty well
no [ __ ] i would know that better than
anybody yeah i'm telling you tom doesn't
know
we no i don't know i said one of these
days one of these days i told him i'm
like
you know one night when we go out you
should put on full makeup a wig a
corset high-heeled shoes trying to get
me to do all that [ __ ] like crustal when
you're on that
in that movie well i'm just saying do
all that [ __ ] and then you'll understand
why sometimes i'd be like man i'm just
like ugh
no she can't walk she underestimates me
if if i [ __ ] went to some kind of
drag event
where we're gonna [ __ ] go to the club
for drag night and [ __ ] the women all
got dressed like men and men all just
kind of dressed like women
i'd be hot as [ __ ] i could walk in all
that [ __ ] well let's see it i could do
it
yeah i'd have to practice well
yeah let let's see let's see you walk in
my business i'm an extra actor
i could do that no problem okay yeah
yeah female impersonation yeah i could
do it
yeah you think you look [ __ ] crazy
though it would look crazy i didn't have
to get the [ __ ] right kind of clothes
to hide by [ __ ]
by build i'd look like that [ __ ]
transaction we knew what was her name
oh man i haven't seen her i haven't seen
her in a long time gosh we were friends
with this [ __ ] we were friends with
the transsexual prostitute
it was showing up to the club a lot i
haven't seen her in years
yeah she's like damn where'd she go
she's probably in jail she's probably in
jail she's getting arrested all the time
she did get her she was a bodybuilder
when she was a bodybuilding male
got [ __ ] huge all right big arms
[ __ ] just
big yeah i mean the [ __ ] was
doing roids and everything
and became trans and started wearing
[ __ ] little
little [ __ ] baby dolls and [ __ ]
little baby doll dresses and [ __ ]
heels and [ __ ]
and it and we're talking about a dude
stop it poop she's we're talking about a
dude that [ __ ] you know
size arnold okay at one time he got a
little smaller
when he stopped [ __ ] doing roids he
went from one extreme to the next
but he was doing growth hormone and [ __ ]
you know which spaced his teeth out and
everything you know because he had the
gaps in between his teeth where his
skull expanded
he was cool though man he was [ __ ]
hilarious
and he he'd be hanging out with us in
the club
he'd be talking about i just got out of
jail well you got to deal with happy
because
oh they got me from prostitution again
and there's oh [ __ ] who you
thought was getting around i was blowing
this old guy and i was blowing this old
guy
you know [ __ ] in the alley no no i'm
not do say anything bad about looking
trans people not all trans people doing
it
it was this particular dude okay
stop it pope what are you doing people
trying to dig through the goddamn books
in the book
yeah she's it she likes the noise that
it makes yeah and
yeah and then what was funny you know i
mean and and
somebody would say some [ __ ] sideways to
him every now and then
and he'd [ __ ] lose it
and start crying and they want to start
fighting and then they
these people were immediately reminded
that this was a 200
something pound muscle bodybuilder
yeah he was in a dress yeah he had long
hair and women women's [ __ ]
hair he was a [ __ ] ex bodybuilder the
[ __ ] was as strong as an ox
yay knock your teeth out you knock your
[ __ ] teeth down
strong as a [ __ ] ox probably
[ __ ]
dude that size usually [ __ ] about 500
maybe 550 i mean it's [ __ ] huge
huge biceps uh
you know the [ __ ] arnold claimed to a
[ __ ] benched i think close to 800 one
time
i'm not sure i believe that yeah that
sounds
like that's a lot that sounds like
[ __ ] to me yeah i think it might
have been more like 700
six six something but five hundred four
yeah arnold was pretty big those dudes
looked at a lot
i know but you know they they always
kind of like you know self
granted 800 and something i think it was
kind of high
but um it depends on what he was on at
the time too
but um no yeah he was transsexual but
that [ __ ] would whip your ass he
was [ __ ] huge
that's why he got away with a lot of
[ __ ] that he did
and i don't understand who the customers
were
there was nothing female about that dude
yeah but some people like that
like i said the world is a complicated
place it's a complicated place what'd
you do you just like
pulled up sound like something popped
yeah i pulled a damn um
they got caught up on my boot your [ __ ]
is like you know pulled a rivet
shit's popping off your [ __ ] clothes
it's okay i'll find it i'll put it back
in there eventually
pulled a rivet out of my pants
it was just that little trim piece right
there it got caught on my
it's fine yeah it's going to be all
right jenny don't worry about my clothes
all right you worry about the show
well can i actually get back to it
i'll get the uh i'll get the flashlight
look for it
because see that'll go right back in
sure yeah that happened
okay go ahead don't believe me what are
you talking about
django sure no i mean okay
i don't believe you i know it came out i
heard the noise
he's losing it good thing we have
two hours before we have to leave still
so it's fine
all right so where was i so we were
talking about uh georgia weckler so like
i said this is another one that happened
in wisconsin right around the time that
ed gein was
[ __ ] around doing his grave robbing
whatever the [ __ ] he did
now this was like i said a little girl
she was a third grader so i'm assuming
about seven eight years old something
like that now she was last seen
uh near her house uh which was you know
it was a big farm
rural fort atkinson wisconsin about 3 30
p.m may 1st 1947.
now what happened was she was a third
grader at the oakland center
school and a neighbor
gave her a ride part of the way home
dropped her off to the entrance of um
the driveway that went up to her house
now the driveway was like half a mile
long right so the
neighbor dropped her off at the um you
know at the opening to the driveway
now at this point georgia little georgia
gets out of the car
and she says oh i think i'm going to go
to the woods and pick some flowers for a
mayday basket
because you know it was may 1st
so normally what
what your slayer said tom should go
pantsless
kind of [ __ ] is this man with your
little tiny butt i don't know what he's
talking about
going like that where's the back up a
little bit
let me see if that's underneath here
where the hell did that thing go i don't
know
i'm gonna blame you jenny of course you
are i'm complaining
i'm to blame for everything that's just
how it works dude i'm trying to do a
show i was just looking down in here
oh my god yeah i'm just looking down
there okay i'll give you back the show
thank you can i you can get back to the
show i'm like only halfway can't find it
see look yeah i see it see it that
sounds like a you problem
yeah these [ __ ]
you do this [ __ ] like right nobody wants
to watch you doing that no i'm just
before i forget okay yeah
well that's your own fault i mean i'm
sure i'll get the blame but it's your
fault
so yeah so uh yeah so where was i so
so this little girl she says she's gonna
go out in the woods and get some flowers
now normally her and her little siblings
would have ridden their bicycles to
school but because the weather had been
so [ __ ] the last few days have been like
really rainy and everything was muddy
so they didn't ride their bikes um so
actually their dad had dropped them off
at school so that's why she ended up
getting a ride home and why
because normally she would have been
just riding her bike home and probably
sadly she would have been fine but
that's
not how it happened now she actually got
out of school about a half hour earlier
than her siblings did
and uh got a ride with the neighbor now
the neighbor also had a
um had us you know kid at that school
and they knew each other
so it wasn't like oh i'm getting a car
with stranger it wasn't like that
so she gets out of the car oh my god is
that one of the fish now
jesus christ i just i can't get him to
be still he's gonna
he he's gonna make the [ __ ] [ __ ]
crash i'm the one you're the one that
was like what happened to the thing now
i'm looking for it no i didn't say what
happened to it i just said what was that
noise
yeah i didn't know what that noise was
that's all cause i heard something
popping over there
yeah pop the little eye out of it yeah
that's all i didn't tell you to like
[ __ ]
run around the room like looking for it
stop managing me
i don't care about it okay
stop managing i just didn't know what
that noise was yeah but well you
gotta [ __ ] you build that you build
this edifice of [ __ ] that like
stemming from something that i didn't
even say i just said what was that noise
oh yeah something popped off your pants
i didn't tell you oh go get the
flashlight and like look around for
[ __ ] five hours for it
i don't care about it jesus christ
i just want you to [ __ ] be still so
my stream doesn't crash it's not gonna
crash
see how you do bacon making my [ __ ]
fish go off back there
those floppy fish you guys i bought the
floppy fish for i bought one for pookie
and one for beijing
they still make the noise like they go
but the
but the tail doesn't flop anymore
because the little uh hinge in there
broke i guess
he fixed it one time but then it broke
again pookie keeps sitting on them
she just sits on them until they break
until they
succumb to her will i guess she's just
like
stop moving but yeah so
so uh george's mother comes home is
initially not concerned because she's
like oh you know the kids with her dad
because the dad had dropped them off at
school so she just assumed well
he picked them up as well uh however the
dad gets home at 6 pm
uh without the kid at which point
everyone is kind of freaking out
so they ask around the cops uh and the
witnesses
reported seeing a dark-colored possibly
black four-door 1936 ford sedan
with a gray plastic spotlight they saw
it driving around that afternoon
now this car disappeared right around
the time georgia did deep tire tracks
were later found on the road as if a
vehicle had pulled out fast
uh the driver of the car according to
witnesses was a blonde man
quite young 20 to 25 years old at least
that's what the witnesses said
so this dude was the prime suspect and
has never been identified
um now some people said and this is more
than one witness
one witness that said this but they said
that they saw a young girl struggling
and pleading with a man inside a similar
vehicle in fort atkinson
shortly after georgia vanished um so
they don't know if it's the same kid i'm
assuming that it probably is but a bunch
of people did report that as well
now at first the authorities thought
that probably
georgia like i said who was only about
seven or eight years old but she had
been kidnapped for
ransom her dad was uh quite wealthy and
he was also a public official
so that was the first thing they assumed
however several days passed the girl did
not reappear and there were no ransom
demands made either
so there went that theory so
at this point they're now thinking well
she must have been taken by
asexual predator now the creepy thing
about this
is that georgia who was only a little
girl and i don't know where she got this
idea from
but apparently everybody like a lot of
her friends and family said that she was
terrified of being kidnapped like she
had a weird
like uh i don't want to say an
irrational fear because it turned out to
be a rational beer because she did get
[ __ ] kidnapped
but she was like really really afraid of
it like it was something that she talked
about a lot
um and creepily she did get it's almost
like she had like a weird
like a premonition or something that's
like pretty creepy
so there's this one dude and you just
know that this dude
is a rapist and murderer right because
his name is buford
senate buford senate
now he had just he was a convicted
rapist and murderer
and he had just started serving a life
sentence in prison now he ended up
confessing
to george's murder in the fall of 1947.
now he said that he and a dude
that was with him but he wouldn't say
what the dude's name was he's like yeah
we kidnapped her
at first for ransom and we were gonna do
that but then we gave her some sleeping
pills to shut her up and gave her too
much and she overdosed
and that's how that all went what are
you laughing at it's quite
because you're distracting me you're
distracting me what they're saying in
the comments section what do you think
first of all khan's asked me where my
michael kang wig is it's in the it's
yeah it's in there all right closet yeah
and then [ __ ] ken said ken said the
trt and jay's outfit has tom all
flustered
and right it's like i can't i can't like
he's like a toddler he's like running
around everywhere it's like i'm like sit
down
eat your vegetables jesus christ
i can't deal with it listen
be an adult it's not the copy be an
adult man stop all this [ __ ] stop it
well settle down then stop it settle
down stop it
oh my god i'm talking about people that
like horribly i know that disappeared
and you're like
[ __ ] to show up you're [ __ ] yeah
you're just being a [ __ ] alcohol
and and all kinds of others you're being
a clown i got of course i'm gonna be a
clown running around look at that
cleavage
i'm gonna be a clown around that
cleavage i'm gonna clown around the only
reason i wore this shirt is because this
is one of the only shirts that i own
that i don't have to pull off over my
head
you got your [ __ ] you got your pretty
you got your pretty hair on
my pretty hair you got your pretty hair
on it not like my regular hair which is
my ugly yeah
then you got this well no
yeah i knew it i'm telling you man
where's tila tila
on the show she said she just needed to
have it you need to have wigs one for
every day tom i feel like he's with a
new woman every day
see these black girls [ __ ] know they
know how to manipulate a man's sexuality
see
well it's just now i'm looking down here
that i'm looking on the [ __ ] show and
i'm seeing cleavage i'm looking there
i'm seeing cleveland i'm looking over
here and i'm seeing cleavage
and then there's like it's like a lot of
fostering it's a lot of work
all this [ __ ] testosterone happening
she gave me my injection today it's just
starting to kick in
and we're going to go to the club
tonight it's going to be a good night
tonight
and she's [ __ ] with me about pulling
[ __ ] things out of my [ __ ] bondage
pants
what the hell is going on this [ __ ] here
man has got the [ __ ] stuff how much
it does a lot yeah almost out thank you
tammy says one word for you jenny
handcuffs no
[Laughter]
i'm just wondering where that little
thing handcuffs fist cups i'm duct tape
i'm just getting kind of i'm just
getting kind of like
tripping out like that yeah obviously
where'd that thing go
obviously it couldn't have gone anywhere
they went into another dimension another
[ __ ] dimension just stopped working
all right go ahead
i've dropped many things in this office
that just disappeared and i've just
i've just come to terms with the fact
that there's a portal to another
dimension in this office somewhere
you knock stuff onto the floor and it's
just ridiculous it's never to be found
so uh so as i mentioned this dude said
that him and this other guy had
kidnapped this little girl for ransom
and that they had accidentally
overdosed her when they were given
sleeping pills
he said that he threw the little girl's
body into the blue river
and they searched the river but did not
find her
they did find some ashes in the woods
near where his former hideout was and
they did forensic testing on these at
least as
much as you could do in 1947 um
because apparently they had one witness
say oh we saw somebody burning something
that looked like a
body but they didn't find anything from
that either
so they're not really sure they don't
have any evidence to convict this dude
and then later
this dude came forward and said nah i
was just joking
or i didn't really do it because you
know how these [ __ ] [ __ ] do
i'm going to confess to all this other
kind of [ __ ] now this dude
buford that's what i'm going to call him
because that's his name come on let's go
she's telling me
all right you can only stay out for like
an hour though okay don't get too
don't get too excited just stay on the
porch
so buford gets paroled in 1974. now
not too long after that he was arrested
again
surprise for sexual assault to young
girls
so 1987 he gets sentenced to 20 years in
prison
so it was a whole like parole violation
thing
now so he ended up dying in prison in
2008.
now he was not the only person that
confessed to george's kidnapping and
murder
there was a whole bunch of other dudes
like i said it's
it's sad because it's like you never yes
you have to check out every single lead
because it totally might be legit
and you don't want to leave any stone
unturned but
a lot of these dudes just confess to
[ __ ] because
it's kind of in the media and they think
they're gonna get attention or they're
going to get something out of it
so there were actually a lot of false
confessions
to this particular case nothing could be
proven
on any of them most of them were later
recanted anyway
now again uh they kind of it's sadly
like the
case was kind of because they never
found her and so it was kind of like
forgotten about and then in 1957 when
they raided ed gaines place and found
all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
um you know look bones and bodies and
skin and whatever the [ __ ]
um so then they were kind of like well
this is also the same area of wisconsin
so maybe he had something to do with it
but again they never found any evidence
of it although it is weird that like two
young women although you know like i
said one of them was kind of eight one
of them was like a teenager
but it does seem strange it doesn't seem
like his mo but i'm not saying that he's
not responsible for it i'm just saying
that he's
they haven't ruled him out as a suspect
even though his
the two victims that they know that he
killed that he was convicted of or were
both
middle-aged women and he was kind of
like more of a
i'm going to kill women that remind me
of my mom type of
dude more than yeah more yeah more than
like
you know teenager little girls you know
what i'm saying
all right so let's move on to the next
case
because i'm trying to get through all of
these if someone will
cooperate i'm cooperating did you let
her out or no
she did the same [ __ ] thing again she
didn't want to get to all three doors
and went no each time
well she's not going out then because
like each door leaves she's not
different outside it's ridiculous
she'll run to the door go yeah yeah yeah
you open and she's like nah
well like i said she thinks it's going
to be nice out but it's going to be a
different place it's going to be a
different temperature she thinks it's
going to be a different temperature
every time i open the door
yeah yeah it's ridiculous yeah i i kind
of wish that too but
yeah i know that's not going to happen
so let's talk about
ronald hammond this is another one from
the 1950s now this one's pretty weird
too
so this dude was last seen in old fisher
hall
a former victorian mental asylum which
had been converted into a dorm
at miami university in oxford ohio this
was april 19 1953.
he was a resident hall advisor at fisher
hall he lived in room 225
at 8 o'clock p.m i thought this was very
strange
at eight o'clock p.m he requested new
bed sheets
because someone had put a dead fish in
his bed
random um i guess it was one of those
kind of like
frat print like in the 50s it's like hey
let's put dead fish in everything
i i kind of feel like that was a thing
in the 50s that was like a prank that
you did
i don't know but so somebody put a dead
fish in his bed so he asked for like
fresh sheets
now sometime around 8 30 p.m ronald
apparently heard something outside his
room that bob
like sounded like i need to check that
out so he goes out of the hallway
to see what it was and
he disappeared subsequently
so his roommate comes home at 10 o'clock
p.m and finds that he's gone
now the roommate is obviously at first
not alarmed because he's like oh maybe
he went to
uh the delta tau delta fraternity house
and stayed there for the night or there
was a party or whatever
so he didn't think anything of it but
then when he didn't show up the next day
then he thought it was weird so then he
reported it um
now there is no indication that ronald
tamman left of his own accord uh
all of his stuff was found still in his
room closed car keys wallet
identification watch
high school class ring all of his [ __ ]
was still in the dorm room
uh he had also left all the lights on in
his room had left the radio on
and there was a psychology textbook open
on his desk as if he had been reading it
now he had a gold 1938
chevy sedan it was still parked in the
school parking lot
his base fiddle was still in the back
seat of the car
dollars in his bank account which was
never accessed uh he probably only had
ten to fifteen dollars on his person the
night he disappeared and he was not
wearing a coat even though it was very
cold outside
so they have found no so authorities
haven't found any indication
either that he left on purpose or that
he was murdered
he apparently just went out into the
hall to check out what this weird noise
was
and vanished off the face of the earth
and the thing about him is that if
somebody had jumped on him
they said you know obviously if somebody
had a gun or a knife or something like
that but this was a big dude he was like
he was a wrestler
like he was he was a big muscular guy so
it's not like
you know somebody could just come up and
like overpower him or whatever unless
they had a weapon
so you know they're just saying that so
they think maybe
maybe he had some kind of mental
breakdown maybe he developed amnesia
maybe he fell and hit his head or
something like that and wandered off
now the weird thing about this is that
there was a woman who was living outside
of um
oxford she was about 12 miles away from
the campus
she said that a dude like a college kid
came to her door at 11 and that same
night
and asked what town he was in and then
he asked for directions to the bus stop
and she told him where the bus stop was
and then he left
now there was no bus after this
particular time
because normally the bus would run at
midnight but they had suspended it for
this particular day
so they know that he couldn't have
gotten on a bus this woman said that
he looked um kind of dirty and he was
kind of
disheveled said that he was confused and
upset
he wasn't wearing a coat or a hat um
even though it was cold outside there
was you know it had been snowing
uh he didn't have a car said it looked
like he was on foot she didn't see a car
anywhere so she said it was kind of
weird now she did describe the dude and
it did kind of sound
like this guy um but they don't
know if it was for sure like it might
have just been a coincidence that this
dude like just turned up and asked what
town he was in that seems like a weird
question to go to a random house and ask
that i'm just saying
now here's another thing that's weird
five months before ronald disappeared
he had gone to the butler county
coroner's office in hamilton ohio
and asked for a test to have his blood
typed
which seems like an odd thing to ask the
coroner said this is
i've worked here for 35 years and no one
has ever come here asking
for a test for their blood type that's
so he thought it was very strange and
that's why he remembered it
this was five months to the day before
he disappeared
they don't know why he wanted his blood
type uh
because they're like well he could have
just gone to
a local doctor or he could have gone to
the university hospital the college he
was at and they would if they'd asked
he'd ask them if they would have typed
his blood form uh he didn't do that
now he was supposed to get a physical
examination for uh selective service
because he was going into the army
but they were like well we don't need to
know your blood type before you come in
here so i don't really know why he would
be doing that
so apparently like his parents said that
they had last seen him a week before he
disappeared
um and they said that he had been acting
pretty normal
um you know and he didn't seem to be
upset about anything
as i said he was a wrestler you know he
was in the band he was a good student
um he had he had been dating he'd have a
steady girlfriend but he you know
dated several different girls at the
time now
here's something that i saw that was a
little bit to me okay
i'm not saying this is impossible but
seems a little farfetched so
this woman jennifer wanger now she went
to the same college as him
and she got fascinated by the case many
years later so she started looking
into it in 2010 and spent like nine
years on it she was like working on a
book or whatever
now she thinks that ronald tamman
uh was a murderer he didn't kill himself
or nothing that he was like alive for a
really long time
she thinks that he didn't die until
1995.
now she thinks this because
apparently the fbi threw away his
fingerprint records in 2002
so i guess after like seven years after
a person dies they can throw your
fingerprints away
right because it's like you're dead
you're not you know whatever
yeah um now
from that this woman posits
that ronald hammond's psychology
professor
was in the cia and recruited
ronald tamman into the cia which like i
said that seems like
going from one little like oh this is
kind of weird way
out into the [ __ ] left field you know
what i mean yeah
cia recruit that just seems a little
crazy
that said uh i'm not entirely sure what
happened to this dude
now to this day um his parents are both
dead now sadly
but to this day the um
that college is said to be like that
area said to be haunted like because
fisher hall where he lived
that was torn down in 1978 but prior to
that there were a lot of legends about
his ghost like haunting it or whatever
um actually when the fisher hall was
torn down
they looked for his remains because they
thought maybe he just like wandered off
and died or whatever got murdered on the
thing got buried
but they didn't find anything so again
his parents are dead but his
siblings are still alive and they're
still looking out for whatever happened
to him
going out in the hall to investigate a
noise disappearing
this many years later nobody knows where
the [ __ ] you went
which is pretty creepy all right so
let's do a couple more cases now this
case this one i i can't remember i
thought we had talked about this one but
maybe we didn't
this is one that's like actually kind of
because this was like three women that
disappeared
at one time where are you going go to
the restroom okay
no i'm just wondering i thought you were
just gonna wander around in the
background again
like looking for [ __ ] your hands clean
what your hands clean
always come hold this oh goodness
you don't need me to do that
[Laughter]
well hey deborah just made it in from
work jen love your hair thank you it's a
witch i just bought this wig
we're going to the vampire ball later so
i just wanted to
want to try it out it keeps like going
on my lipstick though that's kind of
drive me crazy
all right so this case
like i said three women disappeared at
the same time this was suzanne streeter
cheryl levitt and stacy
mccall now this happened in springfield
missouri in 1992.
susan streeter she was a teenager at the
time now she had just graduated from
high school
june 6 1992. now
this particular night she um
you know the night that she graduated
she had dinner with her
uh mom at home they lived as i said in
springfield missouri on east del mar
street
now suzanne had a friend named stacy
mccall
and they were going to kind of celebrate
their graduation they were going to
spend the night at this hotel
in branson missouri but then they
decided well no we're going gonna go to
this other friend's house that was in
battlefield missouri instead i guess
they were having like a graduation party
there
so they decided to do that instead so
suzanne calls her
mom cheryl at about 10 30 p.m and says
okay we're changing our plans we're not
staying at the hotel now now we're going
to this other person's house for a party
or whatever
so at this stage cheryl uh the mom
she calls her friend uh at about 11 15
that evening now she had been home
apparently by herself
and she was kind of doing some furniture
restoration she was painting a chest of
drawers
at the time and during this phone call
it did not appear that there was
anything wrong there were no intruders
in the house she wasn't like alarmed by
anything she was just at home with the
dog
or whatever so suzanne
and stacy they came back
to cheryl's house that was suzanne's mom
they came back at about 2 15 in the
morning
on june 7th they had been at the
friend's house and they were like it was
too crowded they didn't want to stay
there so because i guess a lot of people
were staying there because it was
graduation parties and they were like
yeah we don't want to we don't want to
deal with that [ __ ]
so they said okay we'll go back to you
know their mom's house
and we're gonna go to the whitewater
amusement park in branson
later on on that uh i believe it was a
saturday or sunday
now the girls were both had their own
car so
they both drove in their separate cars
to cheryl's house
and apparently sometime after the two
girls arrived
at the house all of them
disappeared the mom the daughter and the
daughter's friend
all gone um neighbors did not hear any
suspicious activity near cheryl's home
during the overnight hours
one of the girls apparently phoned what
oh okay
what now i walked by the front door and
pookie was [ __ ] sitting by the front
door waiting to go out i opened the door
and she ran out
[ __ ] turned a circle and came right
back in
too hot well she's just gonna stay in
then
yeah she's gonna be staying in tonight
because [ __ ] that because she's not
going outside when we're not here
man i'm ready for the club tonight well
it's we still have a little bit
i'm ready click just let me it's only 7
30. yeah he's going to be like
hard to deal with no i'm not going to be
hard to do it yeah you are yeah
that's okay all my boys will be there
they'll keep my control
yeah we'll see yeah we're going to the
restaurant or they
well i'm yeah that would be this i
haven't eaten hardly anything today just
in preparation yeah because i knew we'd
be going to chantel then i'm going to
get some [ __ ] fried catfish
big time it will
who else is coming i'm not sure actually
well demetri and jen will be there
because demetrius dj yeah
so laura common i think not all right
she just messaged me a couple days ago
yes like yeah probably we showed you all
laura
there's a wonder woman
who else coming i don't know yet okay
grandpa says
fried catfish yeah it's it's good yeah
we had some edges yeah we told them
yeah last time we made those clown tails
have fried cabbage fried catfish yeah
and french fries yeah it's good yeah
it's pretty good
i mean all their [ __ ] they have two
different kinds of fish you can get fish
and chips
they have a ton of other [ __ ] on the
menu we're going to record the [ __ ]
we'll post it
i don't know we'll see we'll see depends
on how we drop it if i'm sober enough
yeah
we're going to record the [ __ ] we'll
play i might just be like where the
buttons [ __ ] this because i get super
impatient when i'm trying to
i'm just i don't want to [ __ ] with
anything i mean i'm impatient when i'm
sober too but i'm just saying
um yeah so so basically so
all of these three women like i said the
mom the daughter and the daughter's
friend
all disappeared on this one particular
night um
so they weren't reported missing until
later that evening june 7th which was
like the day after you know what i mean
because one friend was like calling
around being like where the [ __ ] are
they
and they couldn't find them so the cops
go in the house
all of their [ __ ] was still in the house
uh the all their cars were still there
still parked at the house nothing
unusual there
um cheryl's bed appeared to have been
slept in during the previous night just
like normal
her eyeglasses next to the bed there was
a book like turned over like she'd been
reading it
and as as though someone had come in and
maybe interrupted her while she was in
the middle of reading
the family also had a little yorkshire
terrier named cinnamon
and he was still inside the house and
appeared to be anxious
so as i said none of their belongings
were touched
tv was on no sign of a struggle the only
weird thing at the house was that the
porch light outside had been
broken there was like broken glass all
over but they didn't find any other
physical evidence at the scene
so the shitty thing is that
because the porch light was the only
thing unusual
and no one really related it to the
disappearance at the time
like i guess a friend of the family had
kind of like swept the glass
because the glass was on the porch so
they kind of swept the glass into the
garbage without really thinking about it
so they didn't have that as evidence but
that was the only weird thing
um but yeah so all of their every all of
their [ __ ] was there the purses
cigarettes everything
um the only thing another thing weird
the three women's purses
were next all next to each other on the
stairs
the blinds in suzanne's room were pulled
apart as if someone had been looking
outside through them
um sadly like i said because
they let so many people into the crime
scene
this is early 90s um and
when your family members come over and
they're like looking for you and stuff
they kind of let
a bunch of people just like [ __ ]
through the house without worrying about
you know the crime scene being
contaminated or whatever
um and they didn't really know what's
going on until much later
so i ever said your hair looks great
yeah thank you yeah thank you
yeah i told her earlier i was awake you
weren't in here when i said it yeah
um so yeah so the police officers what
they did at first
was they just left a note on the door
and said hey
cheryl if you come back if you haven't
been kidnapped
uh call the cops and cancel the missing
persons reports because you know you
guys have all been reported missing and
we're sure it's fine
um you know so they start looking around
they did like this big huge search of
the surrounding areas
and they found nothing um
one suspect that they identified early
on was this dude named robert cox
who was a robber now he was serving time
on unrelated charges in a texas prison
he had actually also been convicted of a
murder in florida but his conviction was
uh overturned now he actually did live
in the area at the time of the women's
disappearances
and he had worked with stacy's father
at a local car dealership
and he initially lied to investigators
saying that he wasn't in springfield on
june the 7th when the women disappeared
but later recanted the statement and
went back and go oh you know what uh
maybe i was
now he also later told the journalist
that he knew
that all three women had been murdered
and that they'd all been buried
near cheryl's house but he said they
their remains will never be found so
at this point police are like they
haven't found any bodies they haven't
found any other evidence they haven't
found anything any physical evidence
linking this dude to these crimes
so they're not really sure if he
actually did know what was going on or
if he was just blowing smoke like to get
attention or whatever or to get you know
perks
so they're not really sure because like
i said they don't really have anything
to go on
now they did have a witness the this
witness said that they saw a woman
matching
suzanne's description who was the
daughter uh driving an older model moss
green dodge van
later during the day on june 7th which
like i said was after they disappeared
uh this witness said that the young
woman looked really scared
and there was a male voice which the
witness
didn't see the dude but heard the voice
saying don't do anything stupid
now the witness didn't think anything
about this at the time
but after the disappearance was reported
they actually reported
to the police now other witnesses
actually did come forward and said that
they'd seen the same dodge van this kind
of green one
uh driving around various areas of
springfield ohio after the women's
disappearances and a man also told
authorities that he saw the blonde
female sitting in the driver's seat of a
similar vehicle in the parking lot of a
grocery store
and he said that he'd written the van's
license plate number down because he
thought that the vehicle looked
suspicious however
for whatever reason he actually threw
the piece of paper that he'd written it
down on a way
uh before he reported it so when
they brought the dude in later they
hypnotized him and he was actually able
to remember the first
three digits of the uh you know of the
license plate but that was all that he
remembered and i guess they couldn't
find anything about it
now there was a woman who worked at
george's steakhouse
uh this was one of cheryl's favorite
restaurants in the springfield area
now she said that she had seen all three
women in the establishment between 1 and
3 a.m on june 7th which like i said was
after they had disappeared from the
house
now this employee said that all three
women arrived and departed together
also said that suzanne the daughter
appeared to be intoxicated
as the group left the restaurant and
that the mom cheryl was attempting to
calm her down
but this sighting has never been
confirmed
and so they don't know hey pookie yeah
she look it
look it oh she's like [ __ ] that worse
than me
she is yeah she'll be worse than me
she's not worse than you she's an angel
spooky's an angel she wants she's trying
to get me out of here
she wants to play we're not working
let's play
well i know but like i said i'm trying
i'm trying to get through the [ __ ]
then you just keep like no i'm not i'm
not going off i'm not different
well the thing about it too is that
you're not even like contributing
anything no no no
right now not right now yeah because
you're you can't be that drunk
no i'm just i'm just distracted
i guess i'm distracted yeah oh my god
get your [ __ ] together
this would be good you think yeah yeah
yeah so they don't know if if this
sighting was actually legit or not but
like i said this server had actually
seen them before because this was uh one
of the restaurants that they that these
three women went to
um some other witnesses said they heard
women screams and the squeal of tires
in eastern greene county missouri during
the early hours of june 7th
but again they there was a search and
nothing was found
a composite sketch of an unidentified
transient man
was released in the days after the
disappearances this dude
was allegedly seen by witnesses near
cheryl and suzanne's residence in early
june of 1992 so they don't know if he
was like stalking them or what
uh they don't know if he was involved in
the case um but they did rule out
you know because usually in cases like
this they're like oh ex-boyfriends or
you know other male relatives so
apparently all of those people have been
ruled out now another this is kind of
sad so this was on this case was
featured on america's most wanted and i
think i saw it too because i kind of
remember this case
this has been on a couple of like uh
disappearances shows because it's kind
of
unusual for three women to disappear
at once from a house you know what i'm
saying thank you victor get your [ __ ]
together lol
yeah that's five dollars for you to get
your [ __ ] together yeah okay
i'm i'm together are you yeah okay
man i got a lot on my mind
don't even don't even it's got a lot on
my mind right now
he has a lot on his mind it's like this
i have a lot of my mind
look at her look like this much all
right deal with it all right deal with
it okay no
i'm doing good okay you sure yeah all
right
so yeah so this case was on america's
most wanted right if you guys remember
that [ __ ] this was back in 1992 like not
too long after it happened
so this anonymous caller calls into the
show
and says that he has like all this
information about it and they were like
super excited
but for whatever reason he either hung
up or he got disconnected
before they could talk to him and he
never called back
so i don't know if this dude was just
like pranking or i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened but he never like
contacted them again
so so this is the thing
what they think happened um and this is
just speculation
they think that maybe uh one of the
uh assailants or assailants might have
been more than one person
because like i said it was three women
so you would think one dude
i don't know maybe he was armed or
whatever they think what he did
was that since the little uh the little
dog
cinnamon was maybe out in the yard like
in the fence
they think that this dude kind of snuck
in the yard
picked up the dog and then came up to
the door
thank you david have fun tonight tom and
he's laughing yeah thanks man
picked up the dog and then came to the
door and was like oh my god i found your
dog like wandering around the
neighborhood they think that
is maybe what happened because the dog
seemed like super freaked out right and
he was just like what the [ __ ] is going
on
so they're speculating that this dude
that's how he got them to open the door
right that he came up with the dog um so
they kind of looked into you know the
women's backgrounds because they always
do that in this situation
uh cheryl the mom she had actually just
moved to springfield in 1980 she was
originally from seattle
now she had divorced her first husband
who's brent streeter they actually did
look into his background
as well this was shortly after suzanne
was born um
the weird thing about them is that they
divorced but then they kept living
together because she wanted to get
welfare i guess
yeah you know and if they were married
she wouldn't get as much so just like oh
we'll still live together but we'll not
be married because i'll get more money
that way
thank you victor have some money tom
[Laughter]
yeah thanks big
so well that was david said i'm sending
you all a movie oh okay cool okay cool
all right i'm excited
i like movies all right i like movies
i like money you like money yeah make
sure i don't already have it though
well i don't know okay i'm just telling
him that make sure i don't already have
the movie
i got a huge catalog he does yeah
um but yeah so so so the husband said
that hey why don't we live together and
then we'll get divorced you can get
welfare and she was like nah [ __ ] that
so she uh took off and lived in her
apartment complex and she actually lived
there for free because she did
she lived there as like an apartment
manager like she did repairs around the
apartment complex like in exchange for
free rent that's what
that's what she did um after her uh
daughter was born
so the daughter didn't actually know the
dad no the dad because they
separated before now they actually moved
into this house where they were
kidnapped from like two months before
they
disappeared uh cheryl had also had a
second husband named don
levitt uh and they divorced in 1989.
now this dude i guess he took off
and disappeared also like on purpose
and so he kind of saddled
cheryl with all his debts because the
debt collectors couldn't find him
so they're like hey you're the wife
you're on the hook so
she was kind of pissed about that so i'm
just saying now suzanne the daughter she
worked at a movie theater in 1992 she
was going to enroll in cosmetology
school
she also had some learning disabilities
i think she was maybe dyslexic
um so they were actually
cheryl and suzanne uh you know the they
don't really talk about the
stacey mccall who was just like a friend
but like i said she disappeared too
um but they actually cheryl and suzanne
i don't know about uh stacy but they
were declared legally dead in 1997 which
is only five years after their
disappearance i guess their relatives
did that
uh but as uh as of 2021
nobody knows where any of these three
women went to like i said no sign of a
struggle in the house obviously they
didn't go anywhere on purpose because a
lot of cars and all their [ __ ] was still
there
they just vanished off the face of the
earth and have never been found
so let's talk about we're gonna talk
about one more case okay you can you
handle that
yeah what's weird is that you got a
comment from victor garcia there and i
didn't get it yeah you all need to do a
matinee on board
it was kind of like i accidentally
made victor garcia invisible to me
somehow
or you have the swearing filter on yeah
i don't know why that would be i don't
have that on
i don't have no filters on man okay yeah
top chat
things that are potential spam may not
be visible okay
just go to live chat yes yeah yeah and
then victor garcia
appeared okay problem solved yeah did
you think it was like some kind of
conspiracy
that's something it's conspiracy
yeah i just i thought maybe i had
somehow accidentally blocked him or
something
nope like i said it's usually it's just
because it's usually like swearing and
you just have
it's usually your settings yeah i didn't
see that option there
yeah yeah it's fine okay all right so
the last case i want to talk about
because we're already at three hours
we're good okay and like i said well
and then i still have time it's see it's
not even eight o'clock yet all right so
then i'll have time
yeah what are you gonna eat you're gonna
eat before we go
maybe like a little snack we'll see i'm
not gonna eat anything before i go
all right so the last one i'll talk
about is logan and please i hope i'm
pronouncing this right shindelman
shandelman something now
on this particular day this this is
actually quite recent this happened in
2016.
so this teenage guy he tells his grandma
who he lived with
um that i had an epiphany about myself
now his grandmother says to him it's
like this is kind of sad
the grandmother's like yeah we'll talk
about that later
and they never actually did get a chance
to talk about it because logan
disappeared the next day so uh
he was last seen may 19 2016 in tumwater
washington and has not been heard from
since so
he was raised by his maternal
grandmother he was a football player at
tomwater high school
after graduation he completed his
freshman year at washington state
university which was 300 miles from home
then he dropped out and moved back to
live with his grandmother half sister
um and while he was there he worked
multiple jobs one of which was at his
great aunt's five acre farm now his
family i guess they said like prior to
his disappearance he was going through
i think what one of them called an
identity crisis i guess because
he was um he's mixed race
uh his dad was saudi arabian i think and
then like his mom
was half white half black he was raised
by his grandmother who was white
so i guess he was having i don't know
they said that he was maybe having some
issues about
you know identity or whatever now he was
um
described as he's he was a really good
student he was a quiet dude like i said
he was very um
you know active in sports or whatever
but after he went off to college he kind
of got uh withdrawn
they said that uh he had had some
friends in high school but that he
didn't really talk to him talk talk to
them after he went off to college
thank you david i appreciate the friday
show despite you having plans
well we you know it could be a [ __ ]
we gotta work around we gotta work
around
like i said we're already at three hours
well that's why i wanted to start a
little bit earlier so i didn't feel like
i was like rushing through the [ __ ]
um you're looking gorgeous with your
hair but you're pretty here
my pretty hair yeah as opposed to my
ugly hair as opposed to your ugly hair
hey man we got to put this i'm trying to
make sure you look good i'm just looking
at the damn screen there you look good
in there
well yeah thank you when i have my other
outfit on like i said this isn't the
shirt i'm going to wear this is just the
one i wore because
all right and these aren't the pants i
don't know these i'm just wearing yoga
pants too i'm just wearing it okay
because they're comfortable um but yeah
so he didn't really
so he had kind of like not talked to his
high school friends anymore and he
didn't really seem to make any friends
when he went to
college either and it seems like he
didn't really know his dad because i
guess like his dad's like sort of
knocked up his mom
like his dad was on a business trip and
he was just like you know out of town
and he knocked up the mom and it's just
like bye good luck with that you know
what i mean so it was just kind of that
kind of situation
so he did actually kind of reach out to
his dad's side of the family later and
they kind of like got together but it
was
you know i guess it was a little bit of
strained uh relationship
now his grandma said that around the
time he went missing he'd started uh
smoking some of the
weed some of the mary jane you know
although i don't think that really had
anything to do with it
um apparently also there was some
tension between logan
and his half-sister's boyfriend who had
actually recently moved into the house
with all of them
and logan really did not like him so
uh the boyfriend was actually the first
suspect in the disappearance that maybe
he'd done something to him
but uh he said he didn't know anything
about it he passed a polygraph there was
no evidence or anything like that so i
guess he was dismissed as a suspect
now as i said the grandmother was like
uh
logan did appear nervous before he
disappeared um and it said something
about oh i had an epiphany about myself
and she's like yeah we'll talk about
that later but then they never really
got a chance to because then he vanished
so the next day um this is really weird
so she doesn't so the grandma doesn't
know where logan is right and she's like
okay well i'm gonna start tracking him
by the pings on his cell phone like you
would because it's 2016.
so the phone pings off a tower that was
near his mom's house in olympia
washington so the grandmother thought oh
maybe he just like took off and went to
his mother's house that's not that weird
so then though she starts watching the
other pings
and then so the phone started going he
went down the
uh down interstate five he was going
south and then he turns around and goes
back
north again and then he goes back south
again and then he goes so it's almost
like he was driving
back and forth along this same stretch
of highway just like over and over again
and they're not really sure what at
least his cell phone was uh
ken says thank oh thank you very much
again i'm digging the hair too and the
dirty pillows
that was a character you can see your
dirty videos you see your dirty pillows
they're called breasts
i keep confusing that they're called
breast mama with like i said the young
ones but they're compressed and everyone
has them
yeah yeah get out of me um you know
that's funny
so yeah so so the cell phone was pinging
as though he was driving up and down the
same stretch of highway
like north south north south north south
you know what i mean so that seemed a
little weird
now the same day um this was the morning
of may 20th
2016. so this woman she's driving to
work and she says she sees somebody that
looks like logan
with two unknown white dudes and they're
standing by his car
this car um like i said was logan's and
it was parked on the right shoulder of
the southbound interstate 5 near exit
95.
now she kind of saw him and she thought
it was weird because it's like three
dudes standing by the car like on the
side of the highway thank you again
victor i like you for your brain and
breasts
well that's all anyone can ask for isn't
it
they're they're begging for a photo
they're begging for
oh my goodness well we've got some older
ones
i do yeah i haven't done a photo shoot
in a long time in a while we needed to
do one for the
cookbook so i can get that finished
because it's done other than that
they want a boob-centric photo shoot
remember the one where i did to you
you're like this and you had a [ __ ]
cool headdress on the [ __ ] jacket
there was nothing but just [ __ ]
cleavage for [ __ ] days
i used that as a banner for a while you
still have that photos
i'm sure i do i don't i don't usually
throw a [ __ ] like that away yeah
if there's a way to post in the [ __ ]
comment section
yeah he's getting all like [ __ ] yeah
i [ __ ] i gotta figure out how to use
this [ __ ] better
all the all the blood is rushing from
his brain into his nether region
listen to these [ __ ] well what that's
what happened okay it's biology it's
biology but yeah
yeah so so yeah so she's like yeah you
use this biology well you that's what
you say all the time well of course
that's my excuse
that's what i'm saying so i'm just like
you know pinging it back at you i think
i got it here though go ahead and go
ahead and do the show i'll find that
[ __ ] picture and then you'll like
entertain that picture i'll [ __ ] show
it on the camera
okay yeah i don't even i'm not i think i
know what picture you're talking about
but i'm not
entirely sure you got it so i shouldn't
start talking that's what you're saying
no here first i'm gonna start simple
you're gonna start simple
yeah okay here we go victor says i'm
mostly into dudes but who doesn't like
boobs
oh yeah that's it oh i remember uh you
didn't take those no no no
tony take this tony took this yeah
that's actually that's his guitar
actually yeah
yeah yeah i did a whole i did a whole
photo shoot
that day because he's a photographer and
he wanted some [ __ ] for his uh
portfolio yeah i was like that picture
yeah good picture
okay i know you guys want to see the
cleavage oh focus
we got to put these up in the damn
stream one of the days yeah they're kind
of old
that's several years you still pretty
much look like that
yeah i'm not that much now you messed up
my lighting again now it's too bright in
here look what you did
i used that picture on my uh writing
ship for a long time
hold on where's the face i still have
that headdress too yeah you look like
the betty page in that one with my bun
there we go i made that headdress
actually got a couple more michonne
okay uh
oh i remember this one this is a cute
one
look at this man
yeah i like that a lot of people like
that because i was actually smiling on
that one
[Laughter]
although i don't think anyone's looking
at smiling
there we go focus i want
one more you sure one more okay
yep that's it guys i remember that i
remember that that's the deal
i remember that day yeah i love those
shoes i think their shoes broke i can't
wear them anymore
they kept like i remember in that shoot
they kept like the spikes kept stabbing
me yeah
jenny did some semi-nude ones too for
[ __ ] for special forces
oh that's right i forgot about that
special forces guys i knew
the guy knew [ __ ] yeah he did real
good photography
and he's like he had a good portfolio
he'd get hotties and [ __ ]
take them and [ __ ] kind of special
forces them up and make [ __ ]
we gotta like hold ak-47 yeah ak-47
mack and then he put him in like
he put him in like post-apocalyptic
background and whatnot some of them were
on
playing cards remember that yeah more on
playing cards victor said is that an
anubis tattoo it is
yeah yeah and uh it was
he was um fifth group
and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] ended up in
special forces i was like yeah press f
i'll do it
thank you dc because tom planted that
flag in his own words
you guys are [ __ ] hilarious oh my god
yeah look at what we're doing here you
guys are hilarious
you're killing me yeah you're killing me
webcam no i don't want to focus youtube
will demonetize us
maybe what's up there's no nipple that's
fine yeah
it's fine nothing wrong with a little
cleavage
[Laughter]
you know no they're talking about you
all right yeah
dc said that i can't believe you [ __ ]
up my mood lighting
we talked about it look what you did it
all like brightened up
i don't i don't like it i like that i
like when it's darker okay
you messed it up
all right can i this is seriously this
is the laughing can i believe
we gotta get this [ __ ] down please get
back to this yeah we gotta get this [ __ ]
done you're just like you're like a
squirrel you're always just kind of like
oh look at him look over there look over
there
he doesn't he has adhd no i don't
you do
yeah all right so like i said so this
woman is driving to work and she sees
the car at the side of the road
she sees a dude that looks like logan
like i said she didn't know who it was
time obviously but later after he
disappeared she knew who it was and she
thought it was weird because he was
there and there was two other dudes
and they i don't know it just looked
unusual now
when she was driving home from work
later that day
she saw the same car uh still parked in
the same spot
but this time the hood was up and she
didn't see any of the dudes around
so they asked her they're like well what
did the dudes look like
that were with logan she said one of
them was about six feet tall uh very
scrawny thin
straight blonde hair and a bowl cut
which okay
uh she said that he was wearing clothes
that were like too small for him she
said he had a tank top on it it was too
small
and the jeans that he was wearing were
too short
the second man she said he was he had
shoulder length blonde hair
uh he was wearing a flannel shirt and
jeans but she said she didn't get a
good look at the second guy she said she
only saw him from the side but she could
tell he was
a caucasian dude and could you see his
clothes now
2 p.m later that same day three
different people called 9-1-1 to report
a car that was drifting across
multiple lanes of interstate 90 of
interstate 5
between tumwater and maytown now
this car um apparently there was no one
driving it
it was just an empty car and it was
drifting across all the lanes of the
highway
so it veers across three lanes toward
the center lane and hit the concrete
barrier and came to a stop i don't think
anyone else was injured
now another person who was a truck
driver said they saw a white dude
with either red hair or brown hair
jumping out of the passenger side of the
car
and running toward the woods right by
the interstate
now this person they're not entirely
sure who this was because this person
does not match the description either of
logan or of the two dudes that the women
saw earlier
so they don't know who this dude is but
the car that was crashed
was a 1996 chrysler sebring convertible
uh with washington license plate number
avj8434
and this was registered to logan so that
was logan's car
um they just don't know who was driving
it well no one was driving it was just
like
going across the [ __ ] thing but they
saw somebody jump out of it but they
don't know who that was
because that person didn't match any of
the descriptions now all of logan's [ __ ]
his wallet id debit card 25
in cash cell phone car keys a water
bottle um
and a big grocery snack the stack that
was filled with uh food
like snacks and stuff still was all
found in the car so everything was found
in his car and it was his car
so they started doing a search uh they
did a two-mile radius of the woods
around the spot where the car was found
they brought in the tracking dogs
helicopters everything
they found uh no sign of logan
now a week after he disappeared someone
at the olympia a regional airport
checked in at the airport on his
facebook page
uh but this uh turned out that this post
was actually celebrating an airport
check-in from a year before
so i don't really know who did that or
what that was about
now his family have no idea
what the [ __ ] was going on with this
[ __ ] they don't know what the deal was
with him telling his grandma i had an
epiphany about myself they don't know
why he would leave
without saying where he was going he
didn't take any of his stuff like i said
all the [ __ ] with the car
and like the car just going across the
[ __ ] highway or whatever
um the cops were like well we haven't
found any
evidence of foul play but they we
haven't found any evidence that the dude
is still alive either
so they're not really sure what the [ __ ]
is going on
so uh as of now uh the case is still
unresolved
now in 2019 i believe there was a tv
show called disappeared and they also
covered his case
in an episode now as of this he was 19
when he disappeared so he would be
you know 22 23 years old now uh as i
said he's a biracial african-american
caucasian a male with black hair and
brown eyes six feet tall between 150 and
190 pounds
with a shaved head and a small scar on
his left forearm
uh and they have also they said that he
um
was really really had a really severe
peanut allergy
which meant that he should have had an
epipen on him
but as far as they could determine he
did not have one on him that day
so something bad might have happened
there because he didn't have his
medical [ __ ] so again a very mysterious
case from 2016
there's his family is still looking for
him and that's this one is
fairly recent and this one kind of more
seems like
i don't know the the fact that he was
seen with those two dudes that's kind of
sketchy but
it did seem like he was having some
problems prior to that so maybe he did
like some weird [ __ ] and just decided to
disappear i don't really know
but if he's [ __ ] out there his
family's still [ __ ] looking for him
so you know there you go
victor says they solved this case it
turns out it was meryl streep prepping
for a role for 20 years
[Laughter]
already no no she's
what's the matter pokey she's trying to
get into my closet i want to go into the
other closet
she wants to go in the closet because
again i think she thinks that i go
outside that it goes outside or that
it's another
there's seriously nothing in well didn't
you say to keep that
closed because my backpack is in there
that has the water thing on it and
she'll chew on it she'll just let her
see it
okay i'm just saying that was the whole
reason i think she's trying to go to
another
outside that was the whole reason that
you put the backpack in there trying to
go
for a parallel universe outside yeah
like i said it's like kitty narnia
well it's just kind of like how beijing
likes she wants to get into the
dishwasher every time i open the
dishwasher to
empty it she's like why can't i get in
the dishwasher i don't understand why
you won't let me get in the dishwasher
she thinks it goes somewhere cool
i guess it doesn't go anywhere cool i
promise
it goes the same place that it went last
time you were in there which was
yesterday it's crazy
[Laughter]
i'm just saying it's you know what i
mean but yeah so
what should you guys have any questions
about the cases you know what we gotta
do
at least i got all of them through yeah
you got it all them through yeah oh my
god
it was a good show i feel really bad
like i said because like all these
people are still [ __ ] missing and
then
yeah we're just like clowning like
talking about a bunch of [ __ ] well
there's nothing we can do about it
that's true you know i think each
case was a you know and then of course
you know it sounds it's to sound stupid
when i say this [ __ ]
it probably is i'm not going to say it
[Laughter]
each one of these cases is an individual
case something different happened to
each one of them
it's just some weird [ __ ] that happens
well
i kind of feel like too even if we're
clowning i do kind of feel like
when you mention the people's names it's
like you never know
you never know what it is that
somebody's if maybe somebody might come
across the show and be like hey i saw
that dude or hey i know something about
that dude or whatever you never know
so is it bringing it up is always like
good
same with any like unsolved it's easy to
be mystified when you weren't there
if you saw the [ __ ] well yeah that's why
people are missing if you saw the [ __ ]
go down it wasn't anything special
thank you jay peacher love you guys love
you too [ __ ]
we love you too love you he calls
everyone [ __ ] don't think that this is
a term of endearment
to a power top [ __ ] it's a good thing
yeah we'll see a power top yeah you got
you know i'm gonna give i'm gonna give
y'all
a [ __ ] choker necklace and it has a
little pendant and
diamond studded gold it just says [ __ ]
so you know what i mean it's like a
title you want to hear something funny
in the 70s my mom used to
uh she had she had this uh shirt it was
like a tank top
yeah and it had you remember back in the
70s when they had those uh iron-ons
that were like iridescent real [ __ ]
tacky that said sexy [ __ ] on it
yeah yeah in the 70s my mom was a sexy
[ __ ] in the 70s
you know you know what's really funny
you know the pictures that you took or
that you took of me at mannequins with
jen yeah with that red wig on yeah
and those pic i really like how those
pictures came out but i was looking i
was like oh my god i looked just like my
mom when she was really
younger okay yeah like it looked like my
mom looked back in the 70s except with
different color hair
completely yeah i was just i i never
really realized how much i looked like
my mom
before then well because i always had
bangs and she never had bangs you have
to show pictures of you mom
i don't know if i have i have some i
have some on my facebook i think well
like mom wars i'll show you like when i
was a kid and then i'll show pictures of
my mom's super cute [ __ ] off yeah you
know my mom my mom
yeah yeah
my mom's awesome yeah i like your mom
you're awesome
yeah she's super cool yeah she's good
she's she's a sweetheart
she's she's uh a b
yeah very positive well that's what i
always liked about her yeah she's
she's real like she's kind of chill you
know she's just kind of like yeah that's
how she goes you know
and you know it's funny because she she
had me when she was very very very young
she was only 18. she was only like
it was she had me in september she had
just graduated from high school like the
previous
june or whatever um and
so she would always tell me she's like
she's like i'm so glad you turned out
okay because i had no [ __ ] idea she's
like i was also a child
and uh suddenly i was i you know she had
me on purpose it wasn't an accident but
i was she was just kind of like i just
had no idea what i'm doing what i was
doing and i'm just like so glad you guys
because i have three siblings too and
she's like i'm so glad you guys all
turned out normal
well you know normal that's a relative
term but just you know not
drug addicts or serial killers or
whatever
[Laughter]
i'm like yeah we may look we may look
like weirdos but
we're right yeah we're right we're nice
people
[Laughter]
louie just got here now now i feel
really bad
dude you're at the end of the show man
show's over because it's like
yeah we gotta we gotta go in a little
bit i gotta put some clothes on soon as
she turns it off it'll just restart so
you can watch it again it won't be
it won't be live but yeah it was a good
show
good cool [ __ ] ham it was funny cool
[ __ ] happened yeah yeah i gotta go put
some different clothes on
and yeah we actually put my put my nails
on
yeah actually we gotta go cause i can't
get dressed with those things we got to
be there and i'll snap off
but like i said we want to be there like
right when it opens but like
because it's not that far away it only
takes us like 10 minutes yeah but i want
to get them to eat and everything too
okay well you can eat something i'm just
gonna eat like a [ __ ] i think i got
some leftover spaghetti sitting in there
i'm not gonna eat that it's gonna that's
gonna mess my [ __ ] up all right all
right
so uh is uh terence williams no we
haven't done that yet that'll be on the
next one though
let me write it down terrence williams
all right i'm gonna write that down
victor's asking us to watch um border
yeah i know i saw that okay we gotta
watch that we um
probably on sunday we'll either talk
about the next episode of creep show or
i watched that uh four episode
thing on netflix about the isabella
gardner museum
heist yeah i've always been fascinated
but it was kind of interesting
yeah well like i said i did more than i
did yeah i read a book about it so i was
like really into it
it probably could have been shorter to
be honest it probably could have just
been you stretched it out
well they do that with a lot of those
netflix things it's like you really
could have done that like in a two-hour
documentary it didn't really need to be
four hours long but you know i'm not
gonna like [ __ ] on it too much there's
just like a lot of repeated stuff
but you know i i i'm really into like
heists in general and art heists in
particular
um so i thought it was interesting so
just saying we might talk about that too
maybe we can talk about that monday or
two day whatever but yeah so
thank you everybody for dropping by we
are going to go
out and drink even more yeah hang out
with some people pretend to be vampires
oh my god
your device ran into a problem and needs
to restart well okay okay
restart then it's not on me is it
um yeah so we'll see you guys on sunday
for the matinee show because we're not
gonna stream tomorrow although i am
gonna uh put up a
movie review that i did of flickers up
here tomorrow and uh
so again thanks everybody for dropping
by thanks for everybody that donated
you guys are awesome and we love you
guys we'll see you on sunday
you gonna say anything tom bye bye bye